dans trois secondes des deux dixièmes on
leur demandera de
nous laisser pour que nous puissions
débuter nos travaux
je rappelle que la séance de commission
est retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat
je vous propose car je n'ignore pas
qu'il y aura beaucoup de questions
qu'on essaye de limiter le temps de
questions à deux minutes
ce serait le plus efficace possible
avec Monsieur le Ministre que nous avons
dans le public des élèves de l'école
nationale
de l'École normale supérieure excusez
moi qui sont là et qui participent à nos
travaux ce matin
et j'invite donc les journalistes merci
fermer les portes finalement merci
monsieur le ministre de votre présence
ce matin devant la commission des lois
et d'avoir accepté notre invitation
naturellement celle-ci s'inscrit ensuite
des événements qui se sont déroulés bien
sûr à sainte-solide mais pas seulement
il y a aussi des mouvements à l'occasion
de des manifestations
contre les retraites
naturellement je fais la distinction
entre ceux qui ont manifesté avec leurs
organisations syndicales dans les
cortèges officiels de ceux qui se sont
mal comportés avec des mal comportés est
encore un terme bien faible
qui ont commis des actes d'agression de
violence de caractères délictuels voire
parfois on peut se poser la question
d'autres qualifications pénales
en même temps des interrogations qui se
sont fait jour par un certain nombre de
mouvements politiques ou pas ou
associatif
contestant parfois les conditions dans
lesquelles les forces de l'ordre sont
intervenues
et je ne parle pas d'organisation
internationales
type Conseil de l'Europe en tous les cas
pour un de ses représentants une de ces
représentants un de ses représentants
pardon qui ont fait des déclarations
publiques
à l'encontre de nos actions de nos
services de police
sans parler éventuellement
institutionnellement du Défenseur des
droits qui a aussi dit des choses
cet ensemble
de débat parfois même visant à confondre
le rôle de chacun parfois même inverser
les rôles
crée des circonstances qui ne sont pour
nous en tous les cas je pense au sens
large pas acceptable nous avons besoin
de clarté
de comprendre exactement les situations
telles qu'elles ont été je rappelle à
tout le monde que au moins pour soi les
événements de Sainte-Souline il y a eu
200 blessés parmi les manifestants dans
de très graves et 47 parmi les gendarmes
et sans doute que vous nous préciserez
la nature de leur blessure qui ont été
importantes puisque
un certain nombre de témoignages et ou
de vos déclarations ont montré que les
forces de l'ordre avaient été aussi
victimes de d'agression d'une immense
violence
l'idée évidemment à la commission des
Lois du Sénat j'imagine que c'était la
même chose précédemment à l'Assemblée
nationale les que vous puissiez exposer
la situation telle que vous l'avez vécu
et dirigé et puis que nous puissions
ouvrir
un jeu de questions et de répondre dans
un climat parfaitement apaisé comme
toujours ici même si parfois il peut
être assez direct mais ce qui est
nécessaire à la vérité du débat voilà
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs d'abord je vous
prie de bien vouloir m'excuser pour les
quelques minutes de retard mais comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le Président
j'étais à la même audition à l'Assemblée
nationale
et évidemment j'ai pu rejoindre au plus
vite possible votre commission auquel je
réponds évidemment à ma vitesse d'abord
par par plaisir bien sûr d'être celle-là
devant vous mais aussi évidemment par
devoir puisqu'il est tout à fait normal
bien sûr et ça que les ministres et
notamment l'isateurs rendent compte de
l'action de ses services et de sa propre
action devant les représentants du
peuple salut évidemment votre public et
ceux qui nous regardent peut-être en
guise d'introduction puisque
effectivement les choses sont un peu
complexes mélangeant à la fois des
exections extrêmement fortes qui ont
lieu au milieu urbain pendant ou à côté
des manifestations pour la réforme
contre la réforme des retraites avec
Sainte Soline qui évidemment ni le même
milieu mais il y aura
ni même le même but en l'occurrence des
bassines ni les mêmes actions ont résumé
une semaine de maintien de l'ordre pour
faire très vite comme le dit la presse
ou les attaques politiques en question
et donc je souhaitais vous présenter ce
petit ce petit porpone comme on dit à
Tourcoing qui résume les quelques sujets
que je voudrais évoquer devant vous est
telle que les choses sont vues par le
ministère de l'Intérieur je précise par
ailleurs que de nombreuses enquêtes
judiciaires sont ouvertes pour
s'insoline comme pour certaines
manifestations non autorisées ou
sauvages à Paris dans l'est du pays et
que évidemment je commencerai pas ces
décisions ces actions de justice mais
j'essaierai d'apporter le maximum
d'informations telles que
l'administration du ministère à sa
connaissance
de ces derniers mois je veux vous dire
et je veux constater avec vous mais vous
l'avez parfois souligné compris au Sénat
pour des questions d'actualité qu'il y a
eu de nombreuses manifestations très
importantes en France singulièrement
depuis le début de la réforme des
retraites décidées par le gouvernement
avec parfois plus d'un million de
personnes dans les rues pour plus de 300
actions sans que rien de majeur de ce
soit déroulé en incident
le sujet de la présentation que je vais
vous faire ce n'est pas de penser qu'à
un problème de maintien de l'ordre c'est
qu'il y a un problème d'ultra gauche
c'est pas un problème de maintien de
l'or d'être policiers c'est un problème
de violence
urbaine de guérilla qui n'a rien à voir
avec le match j'adore classique et je
pense qu'on se tromperait ça ne veut pas
dire qu'il faut pas améliorer toujours
le maintien de vente qui est un exercice
extrêmement ingrat et difficile mais que
il y a un moment particulier de violence
qui n'est notamment à partir du 16 mars
lorsque l'ultra gauche décide de prendre
en otage de mouvement social ou
d'accentuer
des exactions notamment de l'écologie
radicale à sainte-solide et on voit bien
que dans le petit tableau que je vous
présente évidemment ce document est à
votre disposition monsieur le Président
il y a alors qu'il y a quasiment un
million de moyenne de manifestants en
France d'ailleurs chacun souligne
l'action du préfet de police chacun son
signe le nouveau schéma du maintien de
l'or du ministère de l'Intérieur puisque
il ne se passe pas grand chose en tout
cas du point de vue de sécurité et tant
mieux pour les manifestants et pour la
liberté de de manifester il y a très peu
de policiers blessés police en tout cas
ils le sont très légèrement et dans des
conditions si j'ose dire classique
d'action de manifestations nombreuses
sur le territoire et très peu
d'interpellations en tout cas par
rapport au nombre de personnes qui
manifestent
ces jours-là et puis la journée qui est
en rouge c'est une journée évidemment
extrêmement important du point de vue du
changement de l'action non pas des
manifestants mais de ceux qui utilisent
ces journées comme étant des journées de
violence c'est à dire pour nous une
partie de l'ultra gauche puisque nous
avons une manifestation qui est
d'ailleurs et moins importante en nombre
que celle du 7 mars par exemple ou celle
du 31 janvier mais qui se traduit par
552 blessés chez les forces de l'ordre
rien que chez les forces de l'ordre ce
jour-là
et 428 interpellations et pourquoi parce
que c'est la présentation suivante parce
que nous documentons que l'ultra gauche
décide à partir du 16 mars d'infiltrer
le mouvement social et d'en prendre la
direction ou tenter d'en prendre la
direction je vous ai mis des citations
des notes de la DRPP des reinstoriaux de
la DGSI qui constitue en effet le fait
que nous avions prévu le fait que des
groupuscules des personnes qu'elles
soient françaises ou étrangères allaient
organiser contre les symboles du capital
je cite évidemment les notes contre les
forces de l'ordre contre les
institutions contre ce qui représente
l'État ou le service public des attaques
qui n'ont d'ailleurs rien à voir avec
retraite rien à voir avec l'écologie et
notamment le travail sur l'eau et
l'agriculture ces notes monsieur le
Président je le sais que vous le savez
mais je dis pour que chacun comprenne
sont à la disposition du Parlement pour
la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement
je ne peux qu'inviter la délégation
parlementaire enseignement de convoquer
les chefs de service qui sont sous ma
responsabilité de faire communiquer les
notes classées secrètes au confidentiel
elles sont nombreuses elles sont
documentées elles ont toutes dans le
même sens les élus tous les jours
évidemment de la violence de l'ultra
gauche que l'on distingue bien de la
manifestation classique bien évidemment
d'ailleurs je veux redire que malgré
cette violence ultra gauche les
manifestations classiques se sont
quasiment toujours déroulées dans
d'excellentes conditions y compris pour
les caresses syndicaux à une exception
près notamment à Paris à Rennes et à
Nantes on serait d'ailleurs expliqué que
ça décale et d'ailleurs la manifestation
de la semaine dernière s'est déroulée
conformément évidemment à ce qu'elles
nous ont demandé
le depuis le 16 mars nous comptons
énormément de difficultés pour les biens
et les personnes
1851 interprétations dans toute la
France
299 atteintes contre l'institutions
publiques des préfectures de
sous-préfecture des commissariats des
mairies et notamment des mairies qui
n'ont rien à voir avec la réforme des
retraites ou le soutien la réforme des
retraites ce qui serait déjà pas
excusable mais qui pourrait
éventuellement s'expliquer la mairie de
Bordeaux chacun sait que c'est sa mère
Europe Écologie Les Verts qui condamne
la réforme des retraites a été
évidemment comme chacun le sait incendié
les mairies d'arrondissement à Lyon et
on pourrait multiplier les exemples des
conseils départementaux ou des tribunaux
à Nantes qui ont été
envahis ou saccagé 132 atteintes de
permanence parlementaire et politique
33 plaintes demande de gouvernement ou
d'élus pour menacer outrage pris rien
que dans le giron la préfecture de
police à Paris et des dégradations
majeures de 19500 incendies de voies
publiques 58 incidents de véhicules
légers très incident de bâtiments en une
semaine c'est un bilan extrêmement lourd
auquel a fait face des policiers
gendarmes qui traduisent le fait que ce
n'est pas la réforme des retraites qui
est en cause il est manifestants contre
la réforme des retraites mais bien des
gens qui ont voulu utiliser
ces moments de mobilisation pour
attaquer les symboles et les personnes
qui représentent la République quelques
images que vous avez vu ou par pas vu
c'est le droit n'a pas été je crois
publier très abondamment c'est le
saccage de la mairie du mairie
d'arrondissement à Lyon la photo
esthétique mais extrêmement violente de
du porche de la mairie de Bordeaux
enflammée rappelons que tous ces
manifestations y compris pour le
commissariat de Lorient et la préfecture
la sous-préfecture de Lorient euh
commissariat a été attaqué et et il a
fallu d'ailleurs que la préfecture dans
ce département
en position d'attaque classique comme on
a connu au Puy-en-Velay à l'époque la
radicalisation d'une partie des gilets
jaunes a fait de très nombreux blessés y
compris chez les sapeurs-pompiers qui
venaient éteindre ses feux et si je
prends l'exemple de Bordeaux le passage
la manifestation à Bordeaux il y a eu du
monde à 18000 personnes à Bordeaux ce
jour-là c'est une grosse manifestation
sociale contre la réforme des retraites
ne passez pas devant la mairie de
Bordeaux et ce n'était pas aux horaires
de la mairie de Bordeaux c'était pas aux
horaires de la manifestation d'ailleurs
la gare de statique d'Amérique Bordeaux
avait été levée puisqu'on était tard le
soir et que évidemment ça n'a rien à
voir avec la manifestation syndicale
classique de la journée
alors
on s'est concentré sur Paris ces
derniers temps et on s'est concentré sur
l'action des services de police des
vidéos sont souvent diffusées pas
toujours favorables aux forces de
l'ordre je vais vous donner de la petite
vidéo de des forces de l'ordre qui sont
à Lyon dans une rue perpendiculaire
après la manifestation
ça dure 15 minutes comme ça
la taille des PV sont extrêmement
impressionnants on peut passer à
d'autres sujets regarder à Dijon ou la
manifestation qui n'a rien à voir avec
celle des retraites dans une rue
perpendiculaire sur trouver des bijoux
ou l'ultra gauche on prend un parti de
façon extrêmement violente quelques
forces de l'ordre qui sont en faction et
qui sont de l'autre côté de la rue ils
sont quand même extrêmement nombreux
nous avons la possibilité
de voir cet immeuble parisien je
voudrais dire que heureusement parfois
pourquoi les forces de l'ordre
interviennent pour protéger les biens et
pourquoi ils viennent interdire des
médecins des incendies dans cet immeuble
parisien place de l'Opéra que je place
de l'Opéra il y a le 23 personnes dans
cet immeuble peut parfois agression des
des poubelles on a dû les évacuer dans
de nombreux enfants on était
objectivement à quelques minutes d'un
drame puisque l'immeuble commençait à
prendre feu
la police a dû intervenir de façon
violente forte pour mettre interpellé
les incendiaires et les sapeurs-pompiers
de Paris ont été pris à parti au début
de propagation
donc c'est aussi une réponse parce que
j'entends dans les médias ce matin
nationale pourquoi vous mettez des
policiers des gendarmes pour protéger
des biens sachant que la vie des
personnes vaut mieux que bien et que
vous savez qu'il y aura violence bon
avec des raisonnements comme ceci je
peux laisser saccager le Sénat sans que
personne ne dit rien puisque si je mets
des policiers des gendarmes devant on
dira vous cherchez la confrontation on
peut marcher dans les champs des
agriculteurs sont que personne ne disent
rien je trouve ça normal de violer la
propriété publique des pertes privées
des personnes où on peut laisser la
Mairie du 11e arrondissement sur saccagé
comme c'était le cas jeudi dernier si
les motos de la brave n'étaient pas à
présent donc oui la police est
gendarmerie sont là pour protéger autant
les biens que les personnes et par
ailleurs indépendamment de la propriété
qui est comme un droit non seulement
constitutionnel mais à droit propre à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme il est
évident que il y a des difficultés pour
les personnes comme on l'a vu dans cet
immeuble à Paris alors sainte Soline
c'est évidemment quelque chose de
différent dans la nature et dans
l'action je rappelle que sainte Soline
c'est depuis plus d'un an des exactions
extrêmement fortes contre les
agriculteurs contre de production de
nombreuses personnes interpellées
c'était le cas en 2021 en 2022 de
manifestations dont une extrêmement
violente a eu lieu avec déjà 500 ultra
gauche black bloc et pas forcément que
français en octobre 2 avec 61 gendarmes
blessés dans certains extrêmement
gravement et donc on connaissait ce
rendez-vous de sainte Soline avec un
important travail préparatoire de notre
part évidemment qui sera soumis bien sûr
aux enquêtes judiciaires je vais
d'ailleurs dire que cette manifestation
a été interdite
par la préfète des Deux-Sèvres qui à
plusieurs reprises a fait des
conférences de presse le 10 mars a écrit
aux organisateurs je mets des guillemets
le collectif passe non merci les
soulèvements de la terre mais c'est
aussi le cas la Confédération paysanne
elle n'a pas eu de réponse à ses
courriers madame la préfète mais elle a
eu des communiqués de presse pour dire
que ces personnes maintenaient ces
manifestations malgré l'interdictions de
conférence de presse de la préfète de
des Deux-Sèvres une conférence de presse
la veille du procureur de la République
rappelant d'ailleurs aux organisateurs
c'est un point très important monsieur
le Président que c'est eux qui sont
responsables notamment des secours
chacun sait vous avez été en
responsabilité locale que c'est celui
qui organise une manifestation qu'elle
soit culturelle festive et autres que ce
sont les organisateurs qui organisent
des secours mais évidemment comme les
ordinateurs n'ont pas voulu évoquer ce
sujet et que non pas mis en place
évidemment de ce cours de secours on
reparlera tout à l'heure de de la
polémique de la fake news qui a circulé
on voit bien que le sujet était
évidemment de mettre le propre sur
l'état et ses agents plutôt que
d'organiser ses secours nous avons
rappelé à chacune et à chacun à sa tombe
d'interdictions malgré la direction
manifestation je pense notamment aux
arrêtés pris par Madame la préfète pour
l'interdiction de transport d'armes
sachez que cet arrêté transportable qui
semble frapper du Creux du bon sens a
été attaqué au tribunal par la Ligue des
droits de l'homme le tribunal
administratif a validé fort heureusement
le travail de la préfète des Deux-Sèvres
mais pour vous dire dans quel état
d'esprit un certain nombre de personnes
étaient en vue de cette manifestation je
veux aussi dire que nous avons préparé y
compris au niveau du ministère de
l'Intérieur et de moi-même par trois
réunions le le travail de la préfète et
du général le gendarmerie zonal ainsi
qu'une réunion présidée par la première
ministre elle-même le mercredi 22 mars
en centre de crise qui regroupait les
ministres de la Justice de l'intérieur
de l'écologie et de l'agriculture et de
nombreux services dans les services de
renseignement
que savions-nous nous nous savions que
non seulement il y aurait un
rassemblement extrêmement fort de
personnes ultra gauche à Sainte Soline
il y avait aussi des manifestants
pacifiques d'ailleurs une autorisation a
été donnée pour la ville de Melle Amel
il y a eu une manifestation avec
plusieurs milliers de personnes
pacifiques ou les gens pouvaient dire
leur opinion évidemment contre les
bassines et il y a eu une manifestation
extrêmement violente dans les champs à
proximité des racines qui elles
n'étaient pas autorisée donc si les gens
voulaient continuer à manifester leur
opinion contre les bassines vous pouvez
le faire évidemment Amel et nous avons
travaillé non seulement au contrôle des
frontières parce que les services de
renseignement allemand italien Suisse
espagnol évoquaient le fait que leur
ultra gauche voulait venir à Sainte
Soline nous avons d'ailleurs interpellé
un certain nombre de personnes assez
frontières en prenant des ce qu'on
appelle des iat des interdictions
d'arriver sur le territoire national par
la DGSI la dpagi et nous avons fait
beaucoup de contrôle notamment autour de
sainte Soline pour l'arrivée je rappelle
qu'il y a eu quand même 24000 véhicules
contrôlés pendant les trois jours qui
ont précédé
62 couteau fantasy 76 boules de pétanque
13h 5 matraques et battent de baseball 6
bidons d'essence va aérosols de gaz des
marchés d'artifice un moment donc festif
se préparait à Sainte-Soline en toute en
toute pacifisme comme évidemment chacun
pourra le constater du coup 3200
policiers gendarmes et notamment des
gendarmes ont été mobilisés je rappelle
qu'à sainte Soline il n'y avait pas il y
a pas qu'une bassine il y a plusieurs
bassines dans les Deux-Sèvres qui
auraient pu être attaqués de façon
différente la concentration s'est faite
à Sainte Soline conformément
renseignement que nous avons eu mais
3200 gendarmes c'était pas que pour
s'insoline c'était pour l'ensemble du
département des Deux-Sèvres et je
voudrais rappeler ici que les armes avec
lesquels se baladent la gendarmerie ne
sont pas les armes des casseurs on me
dit qu'il y a des armes de guerre qui
ont été utilisées oui par les casseurs
la gendarmerie n'utilise pas de cocktail
Molotov par exemple vous voyez c'est pas
quelque chose que l'on peut utiliser les
drones ne sont pas autorisés par les
gendarmes je le dis devant le président
de la commission des lois une nouvelle
fois seuls les policiers gendarmes ne
peuvent pas faire voler des drones en
France par contre les casseurs ont pu
faire voler des drones ça c'était une
difficulté que nous avons nous n'avons
pas pu avoir une vue totale du
dispositif même sur l'autorisation du
procureur de la République qui a refusé
les demandes de la préfète en revanche
les casseurs ont fait voler des drones
pour faire regarder le dispositif et
pour savoir où on devait attaquer
deuxièmement je regrette puisque on me
dit mais vous connaissiez vous avez des
informations pourquoi vous avez
interpellé les personnes la PPL de
Monsieur Retailleau reprise par le
ministre Christophe Castaner a été
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
et empêche le ministre de l'Intérieur et
ses services qui ne faut qu'appliquer le
droit d'interpeller des personnes que
l'on qualifie de deux casseurs et qu'on
connaît comme tel dans une à la veille
d'une manifestation voilà pourquoi nous
nous préparions à un moment de
confrontation non pas parce que nous le
souhaitions comme je l'entends ici ou là
mais parce qu'il était inévitable
puisque personne n'a respecté l'État de
droit dans le camp des manifestants
casseurs ni les arrêter d'interdiction
de la préfète ni les arrêter de
transport d'armes ni l'inventeur réalisé
de secours malgré tout ni des images
pour la gendarmerie ni bien évidemment
de d'interdiction a priori de paraître
sur ce site qui était une propriété
privée je rappelle l'agriculteur dont
tout le monde se fiche de savoir
pourquoi leur propriété a été assez
foulée pendant des jours et des jours 60
secondes je reviendrai pas plus sur les
notes de renseignement elles sont là
aussi totalement à votre disposition
pour la délégation parmentale du
renseignement il y a eu énormément
d'objets saisis je rappelle que en plus
de ce que je vous ai cité en amont 800
objets qualifiés d'armes armure blanche
côté Molotov on a eu des chalumeaux on a
eu des tronçonneuses on a eu un certain
nombre d'objets aussi sympathiques que
cela qui ont été saisis 48 gendarmes ont
été blessés dans certains gravement et
quatre individus de ces grièvement dans
de très grièvement dont un serait encore
à lutter pour la vie on a évidemment une
pensée pour eux bien évidemment les
enquêtes judiciaires vous l'avez entendu
par le procureur de la République de
Rennes seront de diront la vérité de ce
qui s'est passé dans la grande confusion
qui était sainte Soline je reviens très
rapidement sur la chronologie découvrir
que dès le vendredi on a dû couper la
ligne LGV entre Poitiers et Angoulême
parce que il y a eu un envahissement 300
bla bloc avait déjà attaqué les
gendarmes mobiles dès le vendredi et
puis le samedi par deux fois des
cortèges de casseurs ont attaqué à coup
de cocktail Molotov et de pierre comme
on l'a tous vu à la télévision je crois
cette cette ligne de gendarme qui
protégeait je rappelle une décision de
justice
dans les Deux-Sèvres indépendamment de
ce que nous pouvons penser des bassines
ou non et du réchauffement climatique et
d'utilisation de l'eau par les
agriculteurs ce n'est pas le sujet les
gendarmes et les policiers faisaient
respecter l'interdiction de
manifestations de la gendarme de la
préfète la propriété privée pour les
agriculteurs et les décisions de justice
les policiers gendarmes ont fait
respecter l'édition de justice l'édition
de justice ont donné droit à la
construction de de ses bassines
évidemment si l'opinion de chacun est
supérieure des sons de justice et du
coup de enclencher ou non la force
publique nous ne sommes pas dans le même
état droit que nous connaissons je
voudrais revenir par contre sur un point
très important
peut-être pas anticiper les questions
monsieur le Président mais ça a touché
profondément l'honneur des gendarmes sur
les secours qui auraient empêché
d'intervenir les paris forces de l'ordre
j'ai d'ailleurs une question d'actualité
chez quelqu'un de s'en rappelle dans
votre assemblée la semaine dernière
évoqué sans grande nuance je veux ici
dire d'abord que le travail
journalistique a permis de démontrer que
c'était une fake news et c'est une très
bonne chose mais il a fallu quand même 5
jours d'insultes et d'atteinte à
l'honneur des gendarmes pour savoir
qu'effectivement les secours n'ont pas
été empêchés d'intervenir par les forces
de l'ordre à 13h49 un premier appel et
aux données aux pompiers et à 13h50 au
SAMU il faut géolocaliser ces personnes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
savez pour être élu ruraux pour une très
grande partie d'entre vous que
intervenir sur un champ long de 6 km²
sans connaître la rue et le numéro parce
que comme ça que vous faites quand vous
appelez les pompiers ou le SMUR vous
dites voilà j'habite au 14 rue de la rue
vinocchocel à Tourcoing et je voudrais
qu'on envoie le SMUR ou le pompier parce
que il y a problème déjà c'est parfois
difficile pour les secours de les
trouver mais là dire il y a un blessé
vous êtes où dans un champ entouré de
champ c'est pas très agréable quand vous
avez en plus 1000 casseurs qui se
réunissent et qui envoie des pavés et
des cocktails Molotov sur la tête des
gendarmes donc il faut géolocaliser ce
blesser nous le réalisons sans succès le
SAMU s'engage à son tour pour se rendre
sur le site avec une nouvelle
localisation indicative du baissée grave
il est ralenti ce SAMU comme on l'a vu
dans les images qu'on était ensuite
diffusé soit par des blessés des parmi
les manifestants qui voulaient être
soignés soit par des personnes qui ont
pris la partie et devant la capacité du
Samu à le faire nous dessinons d'envoyer
le médecin de GIGN sur place entouré de
gendarmes et d'un infirmier militaire le
groupement qui accompagne le médecin du
GIGN qui fend la foule au style pour
soigner de ses graves et pris à partie
doit rebrousser chemin le gendarme le
message GIGN à qui jouera à rendre un
hommage tout particulier malgré les jeux
de projectiles les pavés les insultes
seront auprès du prend les premiers
soins et fait le premier bilan médical
nous ne décidons une décision humaine de
ne pas faire évacuer par l'hélicoptère
de la gendarmerie qui était à
disposition se blesser grave parce qu'il
est blessé trop gravement et donc on
doit attendre l'hélicoptère médicalisé
du SMUR qui doit se poser parmi la foule
des images que vous avez vu et
évidemment ensuite le SAMU c'est à dire
si j'en crois les rapports qui m'ont été
rendus publics aussi du ministère dès le
lendemain par la DGN et par la préfète
une heure après une heure après l'appel
ceci étant dit je voudrais vous montrer
ce qu'on distribuer aux manifestants
casseurs à Sainte Soline ce document qui
est très bien réalisé je pense que
beaucoup d'entre nous ne seraient pas
capables de faire ce genre de choses je
crois avec les outils informatiques
modernes c'est ce document est à votre
disposition de ce président aux membres
du Parlement explique comment réagir
lorsqu'on sera blessé après la
confrontation avec les forces de l'ordre
donc d'abord comment s'équiper
évidemment ensuite il faut pas avoir les
identités il faut pas sur la qualité
faut se faire enregistrer sous X il faut
pas essayer de pas être dans près des
gendarmes parce que il va vous emmener à
l'hôpital il faut pas se présenter
spontanément à l'hôpital il faut aller à
l'hôpital après et si possible dans le
département faut payer en liquide et
puis bon je vous fais la liste
évidemment il préfère passer par le
Medic Street vous savez ceux qui sont
des personnes qui auraient un diplôme
médical mais qui serait parmi les les
casseurs et les manifestants bref il y a
même ensuite une petite action pour
qu'on commence déclarer les choses en
garde à vue enfin vous avez le parfait
le le parfait vadebicom avec un numéro
de téléphone d'ailleurs et précisant
d'ailleurs que sans doute la police nous
écoute a contacté via signal au
Télégramme bref ce document qui a été
multiplié et diffusé à tous les
manifestants démontrer la préméditation
comme on dit dans les services du
ministère de l'intérieur de la violence
qui allait si pénétrer et donc les
discours sur le pacifisme des
manifestants qui en tout cas sont allés
confronter les gendarmes je crois est
une fable qui ne décrit que par ceux qui
la disent et encore j'en suis pas tout à
fait certain alors je voudrais dire un
deuxième point monsieur le Président le
plus vite possible évidemment que le
sujet n'est pas la manifestation ou les
manifestations le sujet c'est pas les
bassines ou les retraites le sujet c'est
l'ultra gauche qui en Europe un filtre
des manifestations pour pouvoir être
extrêmement violente et ce n'est pas
caca français je rappelle le G20 à
Hambourg des changements trois jours le
G8 à Rostock avec des heures qui ont
donné lieu à plus d'un millier de
blessés en Allemagne le G20 à Londres
chacun s'en souvient avec la mort de
passant mais aussi les zones à défendre
les fameuses ades en janvier 2023 il y a
deux mois à l'usaz art en Allemagne
j'espère que je prononce correctement de
violon affrontements auxquels les
policiers ont suivi des tirs d'engins
pyrotechnique et de protective une
centaine de blessés en janvier 23 à
Atlanta l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
pour s'opposer la construction d'une
école de police avec des morts et des
blessés bref l'ultra gauche utilise des
causes quel que soit ses causes pour
pouvoir non pas faire faire du maintien
de l'ordre mais malheureusement devoir
répondre à une guerrier extrêmement
violente on a quelques images de ce qui
s'est passé voilà deux mois en Allemagne
pour ceux qui croient que ce n'est qu'en
France que les choses sont difficiles
de manifestants pour les confombres
on peut prendre aussi un exemple italien
[Applaudissements]
et je voudrais rappeler pour aller assez
vite
c'est en Italie c'est en Allemagne et
c'était il y a quelques mois ou quelques
années pour l'Italie on peut pas aussi
des cas espagnols sur la place de mayor
bref toute l'Europe est concernée par
cette utilisation par le tragot de la
violence je rappelle d'ailleurs qu'en
France c'est pas nouveau depuis le début
des années 2000 pendant les
manifestations de CPE il y a la même
chose je rappelle que sous le
gouvernement de Monsieur Hollande
Sylvain était une forme de reptile de
sainte Soline avec 56 gendarmes blessés
on se rappelle tous de ce jeune homme
décédé
Notre-Dame-des-Landes 108 gendarmes
blessés je voudrais aussi rappeler
qu'entre des Landes c'était pas une un
joyeux retour et rendez-vous
d'alternatif Bontin 800 engins incendie
avait été saisi à l'époque et des
dizaines d'armes je rappelle qu'en 2016
au printemps 2016 la loi el khomri a
fait naître des contestations contre le
travail avec une présence ultra gauche
qui avait été dénoncée par Bernard
Cazeneuve à l'époque extrêmement forte
avec un violence niveau violence qui n'a
d'ailleurs rien à voir avec ce que nous
connaissons qui étaient beaucoup plus
forte et je rappelle que la de
manifestation des gilets jaunes à ne pas
confondre avec le début on fait être
aussi cette radicalisation et mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je terminerai
par vous dire que ça ne fait que
commencer 42 projets sont enregistrés
par les services de renseignement comme
étant ceux qui peuvent faire des
contestations extrêmement violentes dont
17 avec une radicalisation du niveau de
sens Soline au minimum le prochain sera
sans doute l'autoroute entre Toulouse et
Castres qui posera d'énormes d'ailleurs
de de de difficultés pour les pour les
forces de l'ordre il y a des choses qui
peuvent éventuellement se comprendre du
point de vue écologique même si ça se
comprend pas du point de vue d'État
droit je pense à l'extension de
l'aéroport de Lille ou la construction
du canal du du de Lyon Turin par exemple
mais il y a aussi des causes tout à fait
écologiques qui sont l'objet de ces
contestations qui sont violentes je
pense aux lignes LGV par exemple qui
sont tout aussi contestés que les
constructions d'autoroute donc je
voudrais vous persuader ici que le sujet
n'est pas tellement l'objet de la
contestation mais la contestation pas le
même contre les institutions
républicaines enfin très vite parce que
on en a beaucoup parlé pendant la loop
me le gouvernement a tiré des
conclusions des difficultés précédentes
mais il faut évidemment le temps que
cela se fasse c'est bien sûr le nouveau
schéma de maintien de l'ordre qui a été
validé par le conseiller d'État c'est la
première fois qu'il est écrit et validé
par le Conseil d'État c'est la formation
qui a rajouté 4 mois c'est le nouveau
centre opérationnel qui serait opération
en 2024 d'entraînement pour la
préfecture de police à
Villeneuve-Saint-Georges le terrain
d'ailleurs été acheté au ministère des
armées depuis la loi votée c'est
évidemment la fin d'un certain nombre de
grenades notamment des grenades explosif
qui ne sont plus utilisés depuis l'année
dernière par les forces de police et de
et de gendarmerie c'est évidemment la
clarification des sommations le travail
qu'on doit toujours continuer à faire
avec les manifestants et surtout les
journalistes évidemment je lis ici ou là
que les Nass ou l'action du maintien de
l'ordre de la préfecture de police
serait contraire au Droit dont les nazes
ont été validées par le Conseil d'État
simplement il y a des conditions qui
sont évidemment
appliquées par les préfets je
rappellerai dans vos questions si vous
le si vous le souhaitez voilà en
quelques mots monsieur le Président je
reviens pas sur les moyens que vous avez
voté par un autre niveau vous les
connaissez il est sûr qu'il manque des
unités de force mobile entre pays je
voudrais dire que dès le mois de juin
cette unité de gendarmerie mobile auront
été créés et présent d'ailleurs pour cet
été trois unités de CRS conformément à
l'autre mise seront créés pour le mois
d'octobre et une quatrième pour le mois
de mars prochain
merci Monsieur le Ministre alors
j'ai 14 demande d'intervention au moment
où je vous parle donc je vous invite à
ce qu'on respecte bien les deux minutes
chacun ou chacune mais le directeur de
la commission est là pour rappeler
l'heure et moi pour éteindre les micros
on en est pas là chacun fera ça la liste
est la suivante pardon le maintien de
l'ordre
débuteront pas Monsieur Alain Marc puis
monsieur Guy benaroche Monsieur François
bonhomme monsieur Marc Philippe de Brest
je suis Jérôme Durand Monsieur Philippe
Bas madame Benbassa
j'ai vu un bracelet tout à l'heure
je prends dans l'ordre où ça arrive vous
voyez donc
si c'est plutôt je m'arrangerai
monsieur bonnecaret même Jourda Monsieur
watteblé Madame l'herbier monsieur
Jean-Yves Lecomte et madame haribet je
prends dans l'ordre des marins levés je
ne regarde pas autrement monsieur la
marque pour 2 minutes merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre cette
audition est l'occasion de de dire mon
soutien absolu aux forces de l'ordre en
réalité c'est la violence de certains
faits qui a été mise en exergue par les
médias alors que globalement les choses
sont finalement pas trop trop mal
passées les violences elles étaient
contre les institutions de la République
et par une étrange inversion des valeurs
ce sont les policiers et gendarmes qui
se trouvent mises en accusation
à mes yeux c'est parfaitement
inadmissible et comme on dit chez nous
il faut parfois remettre les choses à
l'endroit vous le faites aujourd'hui
d'autre part lorsque l'on participe à
une à une manifestation qui est
interdite et bien écoutez on sait les
risques que l'on prend monsieur le
ministre comment souhaitez-vous que nous
puissions faire évoluer notre droit afin
que nos policiers et gendarmes ne soient
pas aussi démunis et puisse plus
aisément
usé de la force légitime
oui monsieur le ministre j'ai envie de
vous dire qu'une fable en vaut une autre
et qu'en fait c'est clair pour vous ce
n'est pas un problème de matière de
l'ordre vous l'avez expliqué très
clairement mais c'est une guérilla qui
s'ouvre et donc vous déclarez la guerre
et bien entendu pour déclarer la guerre
faut accuser l'agresseur faut accuser
d'être agressé c'est classique c'est
clair vous l'avez en fait c'est une
preuve claire tout ce qui a été votre
vous savez monsieur le ministre que tous
les projets de bassine ont été déboutés
dans tous les recours en justice qui
démontent leur non conformité avec les
législation française et européenne vous
savez monsieur le vilis que vous avez
modifié votre doctrine du Batia de
l'ordre depuis le 16 mars les chiffres
prouvent c'est pas que les manifestants
qui ont changé c'est vos doctrines qui
ont été modifiées depuis le 16 mars vous
savez monsieur le ministre que ce qui
s'est passé lors des récentes
manifestations à cette Soline en
particulier ne relève pas uniquement de
bavure d'un tel ou Intel il y a des
enquêtes en cours mais de l'application
destruction et de coïncides qui ont été
donnée avec de nouvelles doctrines de
matières de lampes par votre ministère
vous savez bien monsieur Louise qui a un
certain nombre de faits qui seront mis
en exergue y compris qu'ils ont été
depuis quinze jours et sur lesquels
vous-même vous êtes revenu sur des
affirmations que vous aviez fait au
début et que les instructions au cours
les enquêtes en cours votre rend
parfaitement bien un certain nombre de
choses donc je vais poser ma question
très brièvement l'article Hertz 300 2 du
code de la sécurité intérieure définit
les armes classées selon les catégories
monsieur le ministre bon je vais pas les
reprendre au quatrième et cinquième
paragraphe on retrouve les
lance-grenades de tout calibre et los
projectiles les systèmes de projection
spécifiquement et destinés à l'usage
militaire ou au maintien de l'ordre
ainsi que leur mission ce type de
matériel a-t-il été utilisé à cette
solide monsieur le ministre deuxièmement
des grenades lacrymogènes ont-elles
étaient lancées vers des élus avec leurs
écharpes et en tel était lancée en
direction des blessés loin des zones
dehors c'est mes deux questions bien
entendu je termine en disant que tout
comme vous tous les dégâts qui ont été
causés et chez les manifestants et dans
les forces de police sont liés à vos
processus d'escalade au lieu de
désescalade vous savez le suivi qu'en
France le nombre de morts et de blessés
lors des manifestations et quatre fois
supérieur à la moyenne et à chacun des
pays européens monsieur le ministre d'où
la compréhension du monde vis-à-vis de
ce qui se passe en France merci Monsieur
benaroche Merci monsieur François
bonhomme
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre
dimanche il y a quelques jours nous
avons assisté à un déchaînement sans
doute sans précédent de violence
sans limite qui s'est exprimée à Sainte
Soline et un dépôt de tous les
détracteurs sur le nom respect de l'État
de droit l'État de droit a globalement
été respecté dans ces fondamentale vous
avez rappelé dans votre présentation
générale toutes les voies de recours qui
ont pu être épuisées non utilisées en
tout cas qui ont permis d'agir dans la
pure légalité donc il n'y a pas de sujet
là-dessus vous avez rappelé également le
travail préparatoire du préfet du
procureur et tout le travail de contrôle
en amont qui peut être réalisé pour
prévenir les troubles donc tout cela ne
fait pour moi aucune sujet de discussion
donc à partir de là contrairement à ce
qu'a dit notre collègue benaroche parler
de promeneur pacifique des gens qui sont
équipés de boules de pétanque de batte
de baseball de bidon d'essence de
bonbonne de gaz de mortier d'artifice ou
d'armes blanches et encore de cocktail
monotov il faudra beaucoup d'énergie et
beaucoup de croyances pour nous faire
croire que c'était des grands donneurs
du dimanche ou des manifestants
pacifiques donc ça n'a rien à voir une
manifestation classique et nous avons
vraiment eu l'occasion d'assister à une
volonté claire d'affrontement avec les
forces de l'ordre
les conditions par ailleurs de maintien
de l'ordre ont été parfaitement
respectés
effectivement des tentatives non pas des
fake news je dirais des bobards parce
que c'est plus français et des fausses
informations qui ont été tentées de
diffuser y compris sur les personnes qui
auraient été empêchées d'avoir les
premiers secours et en dépit je dois le
dire de tous les observateurs des
pratiques policières autoproclamés
issus de la Ligue des droits de l'homme
et d'autres associations ou des
défenseurs des droits auto saisis je
rappelle quand même que ça pose une
question le Défenseur des droits est
financé par fonds publics à une statut
indépendant et surtout saisie comme bien
lui semble c'est le présent République
qui l'a désigné et maintenant il ne peut
que se mordre les doigts de la pratique
qu'elle a de sa mission je rappelle
deuxième chose Monsieur le Ministre que
la ligne des droits de l'homme Ligue des
droits de l'homme par un petit phrase et
financé sur fond public y compris de
l'État donc si vous voulez être cohérent
monsieur le ministre il faut cesser de
financer des associations qui non
seulement mettent en cause gravement
l'État avec un état violent policier un
état policier qui est toujours dénoncé
une violence systémique et je sais qu'à
par ailleurs vous avez dénoncé l'analyse
et par ailleurs c'est tout ambiguïté de
l'État on finance ses associations qui
n'ont rien à voir avec l'État de droit
quoi qu'elles en disent à la question un
dernier élément monsieur ministre c'est
l'ambiguïté de votre propos parce que
sur tout le reste je suis d'accord c'est
que l'État n'est pas cohérent et parfois
même ambigu on a vous avez pas de si
vas-yves ça a été abandonné par un
arrêté un arrêté préfectoral à la
demande de la question
on a arrêté Notre-Dame-des-Landes en
février 2018 alors même qui avait une
consultation publique en février en juin
2016 qui a confirmé le projet donc que
l'État aujourd'hui s'étonne après que on
encourage d'une certaine façon tous les
contestataires de Tool qui veut mettre
qui veulent mettre à l'état en bas il ne
faut pas s'étonner que moment donné
cette ambiguïté nous revient dans la
figure
merci Monsieur Marc Philippe de Bresse
oui monsieur le ministre bien sûr nous
partageons le diagnostic et les
objectifs de ce que vous venez de nous
dire avec force argument à l'appui et je
rappelle que la majorité sénatoriale a
écrit une résolution qui exprime sa
gratitude et ça reconnaissance aux
forces de l'ordre nul besoin de le dire
ici il y a une très large majorité pour
partager ce point de vue vous le savez
et nous l'avons démontré puisque dans
toutes les lois auxquelles nous avons
participé avec mes collègues et moi
comme rapporteur avec d'autres nous
avons soutenu les moyens nécessaires
pour le ministère de l'Intérieur la
question que je voudrais sur laquelle je
vais aller directement vous avez dit
dans le Journal du Dimanche plus aucune
ZAD ne s'installera dans notre pays ni à
sainte-solide ni ailleurs nous créerons
une cellule antisèle avec des jurys
spécialisés évidemment que nous sommes
interpellés je prolonge ce que disait
mon collègue François bonhomme quand la
Ligue des droits de l'Homme conteste un
arrêté préfectoral qui prévoit
d'interdire des armes destination sur
Sainte Soline on peut se poser des
questions il y a un certain nombre de
décisions du Conseil constitutionnel qui
ont été prises sur les drones il y a
tous et tous ces sujets là donc à quel
niveau voulez-vous agir est-ce que vous
avez créé une cellule juridique avec des
moyens est-ce qu'on doit aller dans des
projets de loi est-ce que vous nous
associerez à ces projets de loi pour
qu'on travaille sur un arsenal et des
outils juridiques plus appropriés pour
qu'on cesse de de tolérer la tolérable
et donc de justifier l'injustifiable et
ce que vous avez aussi réfléchi au
niveau constitutionnel merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur Jérôme Durand merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre alors je voudrais débuter
débuter en rappelant que que à titre
personnel et au nom de mon groupe nous
soutenons les forces de l'ordre nous
condamnons les violences des casseurs
nous avons voté la loop me ce qui
devrait nous éviter et nous n'avons pas
grand chose à voir avec le train à
gauche ce qui devrait nous éviter pour
la suite de mon propos tout procès en
terror intellectuel alors le sujet n'est
pas le talent du ministre son efficacité
politique c'est reconnu par la par la
presse c'est plutôt son bilan en matière
de maintien de l'ordre du Stade de
France au rut de Paris ou de Bordeaux
force et de constater que nous
constatons trop de dysfonctionnement et
tout n'est pas toujours de la faute des
autres les manifestants les supporters
des clubs des clubs de football
étrangers les membres de l'ultra droite
ou l'ultra gauche il y aura tout le
temps des gens qui voudront causer des
désordres le maintien de l'ordre c'est
fait pour ça alors quel retour
d'expérience autocritique on peut avoir
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre sur
cette action parce que on est piégé dans
un débat et d'ailleurs une certaine
partie de mes collègues de droite là
dans une émiplégie sécurité oublie que
l'État de droit c'est la liberté et la
sécurité et on est convoqué dans un
débat très binaire avec les méchants les
gentils on l'avait sur l'immigration
c'est importer maintenant dans le champ
de la sécurité alors oui il y a les
méchants black bloc et oui il y a plutôt
des gentils policiers ceci étant cette
vision en noir et blanc elle ne
contribue pas l'efficacité de l'action
publique alors quelques questions très
contraintes très très concrètes afin de
faciliter la désescalade un principe
d'importance pour les polices de
beaucoup de pays voisins qui ont eux
aussi à gérer des troubles d'importance
soit vous entendre sur deux points le
Rio et l'imagerie d'extrême droite le
Conseil d'État doit rendre aujourd'hui
sa décision concernant l'obligation de
porter le numéro d'identification cette
question qui pourrait paraître
accessoire ne l'est pas pour deux
raisons d'abord l'identification des
policiers intervenants dans le cadre des
opérations de maintien de l'ordre
apporte beaucoup notamment s'il faut
retracer la chaîne des responsabilités
en cas de mandéontologique ensuite cela
est perçu à raison par la population
comme une évidence que l'on puisse
identifier les policiers la représente
la représentante du Ministère de
l'Intérieur indiquait que le non port du
Rio n'empêchait pas l'identification des
policiers suspectés de fautes pendant
des manifestations pourtant de nombreux
enquêtes de l'IGPN sont classées sans
suite faute d'avoir pu identifier les
auteurs des manquements que comptez-vous
faire monsieur le ministre pour
augmenter le port du Rio au delà des
rappels de cette obligation il y en a eu
18 depuis 2013 par ailleurs certains
policiers rechignent apportaient leur
hério mais d'autres tiennent au
contraire à portée des symboles
empruntés à l'extrême droite alors c'est
la fine Blue Line et cuisson judged
Umbrella Corporation ou John Wick
accompagné de certaine mentions pour
vous faire un tel rappel aujourd'hui à
l'attention des forces de l'ordre pour
dire que police et gendarmerie que c'est
totalement illégal et votre position de
ministre de l'Intérieur donnerait une
force particulière à cette déclaration
et puis je termine par un propos de
Nicolas Lerner qui est directeur de la
DGSI qui dit c'est un peu pour tempérer
l'ambiance du moment nombre démocraties
occidentales considèrent que la menace
d'ultra droite suprématiste accélère
rationniste est aujourd'hui la
principale menace à laquelle elles sont
confrontées merci merci Monsieur Durin
monsieur le questeur Philippe Bas
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre à la parole
monsieur le ministre je vous remercie
des informations que vous nous avez
apporté sur
les récences événements de sainte Soline
vous le savez le Sénat depuis de longues
années a toujours été aux côtés de
l'État pour que force reste à la loi
face à tous ceux qui préfèrent l'action
violente plutôt que de s'en remettre
à la démocratie au dialogue social
et nous restons dans cet état d'esprit
disponible et prêt à prendre des
initiatives pour que l'État sache se
déforme
ce matin il y avait à Matignon une
grande réunion sociale elle a tourné
court
et je vois je dois quand même vous dire
que le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez n'est pas capable de produire
du consensus social sur ces réformes et
que dès lors il ne faut pas s'étonner
qu'il y ait dans notre pays une forme de
radicalisation des luttes
vous n'êtes pas non plus capable de
contenir l'ultra gauche
on a évoqué
Sivens on a évoqué
Notre Dame des Landes enfin il y a eu
aussi l'Arc de Triomphe les gilets
jaunes le Stade de France c'est autre
chose des manifestations récentes que
vous avez rappelées avec des incendies
d'ordures des violences Paris Rennes
Nantes et au fond tout ce que vous nous
avez démontré montre que ce qui s'est
produit était prévisible
qu'avez-vous fait pour l'empêcher
c'était interdit mais où est l'autorité
de l'État quand l'interdiction n'est pas
respectée et que vous ne vous donnez pas
les moyens d'empêcher ce que vous
interdisez là je crois que nous sommes
face au limites de votre propre action
quand les forces de l'ordre rentre en
jeu il est normal
qu'elles utilisent la force pour
laquelle elles sont justement employées
et je crois que il est important pour
nous de les défendre de souligner la
difficulté de leur mission et de les
appuyer mais il me semble que nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans une situation où
l'État est défié certes mais qu'il est
aussi peut-être
déficient pour faire face à ce type de
difficulté et je voudrais savoir de quoi
avez-vous besoin maintenant pour que ça
ne se reproduise pas
merci j'étais seul merci alors encore
deux intervenants sont les intervenantes
madame Benbassa l'homme de la gontriche
je laisserai la parole au ministre et on
reprendra ensuite la liste madame
Benbassa merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre depuis une semaine
vous parlez d'écoute terrorisme de
terrorisme intellectuel tous ces abus de
langage sont dans un premier temps une
offense à la mémoire des victimes
d'attentat et dans un second temps une
incitation à la violence grand
cesserez-vous c'est provocation qui loin
de calmer le débat ne font que l'envolue
même et pour la même occasion je vous
poserai une deuxième question vous
parlez abondamment de l'extrême gauche
mais très peu de l'extrême droite je
voudrais
par cette occasion vous parlez de de
groupuscules qui s'appelle fr DTR que
vous avez
dissous je le sais qui a repris une
liste qui avait été produite par
Français de souche il y a 2 ans je crois
et qui appelle à des actes de violence
en passant par telegram à des actes de
violence contre les contre des
personnalités qui figurent et des élus
et j'en fais partie et j'ai peur je vous
le dis alors qu'est-ce que vous comptez
faire contre ce genre de groupuscules
merci Madame Bassa
merci président monsieur le ministre
vous avez à plusieurs reprises
regrettées on peut le comprendre ce que
beaucoup maintenant appellent désormais
grâce à Donald Trump les fake news et
vous avez raison mais vous avez depuis
le début de ce cette séquence vous-même
contribuez à cette situation et donc je
voulais savoir comment vous envisagiez
la suite de vos déclarations vous avez
dit le 21 mars et vous l'avez répété le
28 mars être dans une manifestation non
déclarée est un délit nous savons tout
ce qu'il n'en est rien et cela a été
rappelé y compris par le Conseil d'État
vous avez indiqué le 27 mars concernant
la brave m que cette la section de la
brave m qui avait été mise en cause dans
les événements sur lequel peut revenir
mais je n'ai pas le temps dans les deux
minutes
avait été écarté tout en disant dans une
ce qu'on pourrait qualifier d'oxymore
ils n'ont pas été identifiés
formellement mais il m'a été confirmé
qui ne serait pas engagé dans la
manifestation de mardi ce qui était
quand même un tour de force et enfin
vous avez indiqué ainsi que votre préfet
de police que il y avait ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un signalement
automatique des violences filmées et
quand on se renseigne auprès de la
préfecture il s'avère qu'il n'y a aucun
service sur ce point et que de fait
malgré l'activité sur les réseaux
sociaux il n'y a pas de dispositif dédié
qui permettent d'identifier les dérives
des forces de l'ordre donc je vous
interroge pour savoir comment vous
entendez y répondre et puis je vous ai
posé une question d'actualité mercredi
dernier à laquelle sur un point vous
n'avez pas répondu donc je suis
quelqu'un de obstiné
vous avez vous avez fait la une du JDD
je vous en félicite sans doute en
indiquant que vous refusiez de céder au
terrorisme intellectuel de l'extrême
gauche ether ben Bassa a parfaitement
rappelé je suis élu de Paris le terme de
terrorisme pour français d'ailleurs et
quelque chose que vous ne devriez pas
utiliser de manière un peu rapide mais
je vous demandais lors des dernières
questions d'actualité si vous étiez prêt
à adresser au membre des forces de
l'ordre la lettre que le préfet Grimaud
avait envoyé le 29 mai 68 à l'ensemble
des de ces agents qui disaient je dis la
phrase la plus marquante frappée à
manifestant tomber à terre c'est se
frapper soi-même en apparaissant sous un
jour qui atteint toute la fonction
policière vous ne m'avez pas répondu je
ne pense pas que vous considérez que le
préfet Grimaud pratiqué le terrorisme
intellectuel je rappelle qu'à la
préfecture de police de Paris une salle
d'ailleurs a été dénommée en honneur du
préfet
alors je vais de la parole au ministre
pour cette première partie de réponse et
puis ne redébuterons dès que
l'intervention s'est terminée par
Monsieur bonne Carrère
bien merci beaucoup je vais peut-être
commencer par répondre à madame la
sénatrice
ce qu'elle dit Conseil d'État sur la
manifestation c'est que j'ai dit une
imprécision mais ce n'était pas faux je
rappelle madame asiatrice vous faites la
loi que une manifestation
interdite
qui n'est pas déclaré prévu depuis le
décalois de 1935 désormais l’article
elle 211 est suivant fait que si on
organise manifestation non déclaré ou
interdite cela constitue en effet un
délit l'article 431,9 du code pénal 6
mois d'emprisonnement participer si vous
me laissez terminer vous allez voir je
suis sûr que vous verrez une cohérence
ça va penser en tout cas je l'espère
donc d'abord organiser mes faisceaux
interdites c'est un délit participer à
une manifestation interdites c'est une
infraction punie de la contravention de
quatrième classe et constitué un
rassemblement de personnes sur la
République dans un lieu public
susceptible de trouver l'ordre public
notamment lorsque le manifestation est
interdite 431 3 c'est aussi donc je
peut-être évoquer le fait que vous
n'encouragez pas à manifester alors
j'aimerais que vous puissiez m'écouter
madame la sénatrice j'aimerais que vous
puissiez m'écouter sans le ministre
est-ce que en effet si vous ne m'écoutez
pas vous risquez pas de m'entendre même
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi
ensuite pardon mais tout ce que vous
avez dit Madame la madame vous la
première ministre ce que je me plaise
madame la sénatrice il faut
permettez-moi juste de corriger votre
propos sans doute en début de langage
sur votre préfet de police j'ai senti à
la fois du mépris et une insulte pour le
préfet de police peut-être le préfet de
police de la République ce serait une
bonne chose je je pense que ce serait
une autre chose à respecter les
fonctionnaires qui sont pas là et qui
sont pas là pour vous répondre donc le
préfet de police la braven oui les 5
individus qui sont soupçonnés d'avoir
été dans l'enregistrement audio que nous
avons entendu et qui était évidemment
scandaleux n'ont pas été sur la voie
publique parmi ces cinq nous ne savons
pas encore exactement qui des deux
personnes ont parlé donc tout à fait ils
n'ont pas été sur la publicité parmi
c'est ça qui n'ont pas été totalement
identifiés une enquête administrative
deuxième vous dites et c'est très
intéressant que j'ai pas le droit
d'utiliser le mot le mot terrorisme mais
vous n'êtes pas la police des mots
madame de La Gontrie c'est justement ça
une partie de ce que c'est de faire la
police de la pensée le camp du Bien
comme dirait Philippe muret au fait
parti manifestement du camp du Bien et
vous vous considérez qu'il y a des gens
qui peuvent utiliser des mots et
d'autres qui peuvent pas le faire il n'y
a pas de police des mots démocratie
madame la sédatrice et vous n'avez pas
l'apanage ni de la morale et du
vocabulaire je mets des mots sur les
choses jeter des cocktails Motors sur
des gendarmes c'est de la terreur parce
que vous n'avez jamais été parmi les
jardins pour recevoir des cocktails
Molotov pas mieux moi je vous encourage
demain matin plutôt que d'évoquer
l'honneur de la police gendarmerie jetez
parfois au chien comme on aurait dit un
ancien président de la République passer
une journée avec la brave pour voir ce
qu'il toute la journée
ils ont comme violence en face de une
journée de la spell a demandé il est
allé les revenus je crois impressionner
BFM l'a demandé pour ses confuserait je
pense que tous les Français ont vu ce
que c'était alors poste de télévision
d'ailleurs le journaliste a été blessé
n'hésitez pas moi j'encourage demain je
vous donne rendez-vous si vous le
souhaitez évidemment c'est total liberté
vous venez à 8h du matin 7h du matin on
prend toute la journée parmi les
manifestations n'hésitez pas n'hésitez
pas à venir malheureusement je constate
que c'est plus facile de le faire de
loin que de le faire de près auprès
d'eux c'est dommage parce que comme à
très bien dit moi je vous encourage vous
avez lu le JDD c'est vous avez des
bonnes lectures le dimanche
manifestement mais je vous encourage à
écouter dans la Casa ce matin sur France
Inter je passe écouter ce matin sur
France Inter mais c'était je crois
extrêmement intéressant et ça permettait
de constater en effet qu'il y avait sur
notre dans notre République évidemment
et bien évidemment une gauche qui
soutient les forces de l'ordre n'est pas
oui mais pour les forces de l'ordre
je reviendrai pour vous monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais pas dire pour vous
comparez mes 68 vous savez qu'il y a eu
7 morts mais 68 madame la sénatrice vous
savez qu'il y a eu 2000 blessés dont
plus de 400 très gravement entre 200 et
400 très gravement vous comparez
l'incomparable et c'est ça une forme
aussi c'est ça c'est de police des mots
vous comparez des choses qui n'ont rien
à voir Madame madame la sénatrice voilà
donc je crois que un peu un peu de un
peu de modération pour les propos et de
soutien aux forces de l'ordre je pense
que c'est ça la personne ce sont des
gens vous savez qu'une partie d'entre
eux qui vous ont abandonné
électoralement il faut vous demander
pourquoi peut-être parce que vous ne
défendez pas au moment ils sont attaqués
et que vous mettez un signe égal madame
la sénatrice entre la police la
gendarmerie et les casseurs il y a pas
de Sénégal parce que oui mais tu as un
signe égal intellectuellement il y a pas
de signe il y a pas de il y a pas de
vous dites les violences de qui viennent
des enfants de qui viennent les blessés
de qui viennent il y a pas de Sénégal
parce qu'il y en a qui ont la force il y
en a qui il y en a qui ont la force du
droit et de la loi que vous élaborez et
il y en a qui n'ont pas la force du
droit et de la loi et qu'utilise la
violence tout court et c'est extrêmement
différent et je pense qu'il faut
rappeler les choses et je je je
suis personnellement très touché quand
je vois des policiers des gendarmes qui
se sentent par des discours politiques
comme les vôtres insultés voilà moi
c'est ce que je vous dis très très
franchement pour répondre
à Monsieur à Monsieur Durin
pour répondre à Monsieur Durand vous
avez raison sur l'autocritique que l'on
doit faire évidemment alors c'est jamais
très à chaud vous savez bien parce que
sénateur que l'on peut tirer les
conclusions de tout cela on en a tiré du
Stade de France vous l'évoquez je pense
que je me suis même expliqué et
d'ailleurs il y a eu de très nombreuses
événements au Stade de France d'ailleurs
vous n'avez pas fait la Une de votre
commission puisque ça s'est très bien
passé y compris d'ailleurs pendant les
manifestations on a eu le week-end à
Sainte-Souline un grand match de
l'équipe de France au Stade de France et
des manifestations violentes et les
choses se sont très correctement passées
je m'en félicite donc oui il y a des il
y a des critiques à faire comme d'autres
choses bien évidemment on en tira les
conclusions comme j'ai dit j'ai publié
les rapports les RETEX et je le ferai
comme il y en a eu au lendemain de
silence il y avait des choses à
améliorer cela cela cela a été fait vous
évoquez alors je passe rapidement vous
dites il y a pas que des méchants et des
gentilles il y a des gens qui policiers
des méchant Black Bloc la différence
c'est que il y a pas de gentil Black
Bloc ça je pense que on peut se mettre
d'accord ensemble donc il y a quand même
un peu des gens qui qui sont plus
gentils que d'autres quand même me le
dire je le dis au passage mais je sais
que que vous le savez j'apprécie
l'introduction que vous avez eu pour les
forces de l'ordre mais je n'en doutais
évidemment absolument pas et eux non
plus sur le rio vous avez raison alors
aujourd'hui le Conseil d'État se
prononce en référé donc il y aurait des
décisions au fond quelque soit cette
décision vous avez raison il y a des
policiers des jambes qui portent pas
leur immatriculation bah c'est
effectivement au contraire aux règles
vous avez rappelé vous-même d'ailleurs
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de rappels règles
faut-il aller plus loin écoutez on va y
réfléchir si le Conseil d'État considère
qu'il nous faut nous engendre de le
faire bon mais vous avez raison par
ailleurs qu'il faut absolument les
identifier pour pouvoir sanctionner
lorsque ces personnes ne sont pas ne
sont pas évoquées donc moi je vais
attendre la décision du Conseil d'État
et comme toujours avec le droit parce
que je suis républicain démocrate
j'appliquerai les règles de droit et me
plaisent ok me plaisent pas et chez la
politique parfois pour les changer c'est
vrai que droit comme vous d'ailleurs
mais quand elles existent et qu'elles
sont décidées par la majorité je les
appliquerai on verra ce que dirait le
Conseil d'État c'est qu'on s'est d'État
effectivement le fait remarquer nous
prendrons d'autres dispositions et je
suis prêt d'ailleurs vous y associer si
vous le souhaitez et vous avez raison
il ne peut pas y avoir de rupture de la
neutralité des agents du service public
en général et donc des policiers déjà en
particulier qui parèrentont un rôle
particulier aucune démonstration
politique philosophique et encore moins
bien évidemment qui relèverait de
l'ultra droite je vois beaucoup de
policiers gendarmes comme vous
permettez-moi de penser que depuis 3 ans
j'en vois peut-être encore davantage de
façon organisée et de façon surprise
quel que soit les policiers gendarmes il
m'est arrivé de constater dans des cas
très minimes qu'il y avait en effet des
personnes qui portaient des signes
qui n'étaient pas des signes que nous
pourrions accepter de manière générale
on doit pas porter des signes sur son
uniforme c'est un cas extrêmement réduit
mais vous avez raison ils peuvent
exister et à chaque fois j'ai fait
prendre des sanctions et oui les signes
qui relèveraient de l'ultra droite ou de
l'extrême droite ne sont évidemment en
aucun cas à tolérer et non seulement ils
doivent être tirés mais ces personnes
doivent être sanctionnées j'ai le cas
d'ailleurs d'un policier voilà quelques
semaines qui
participer dans sa vie civile à
manifestation de l'extrême droite avec
des slogans qui ont été évidemment
confondus par les images puis qui se
s'est retrouvé parmi des gens d'extrême
droite ultra-droites pour pouvoir faire
une manifestation violente que nous
avons arrêté c'est vraiment il y a
quelques semaines de ça encadre
justement des en marge de la Coupe du
monde pour notamment des contre des
supporters dit maghrébins je mets
évidemment des guillemets nous les avons
tous interpellé cette exaction d'appel
lieu parce que la police fait son
travail et ne distingue pas le droit à
gauche de la droite elle attaque tous
ceux qui s'attaquent à la République et
cette personne a été révoquée et je vais
vous dire a été révoqué en plus à
l'unanimité du conseil de discipline
c'est à dire vraiment y compris la
raison syndicale donc vous avez raison
ça peut arriver comme dans tout métier
il y a des gardiens de phares des
boulangers des sénateurs des policiers
des gendarmes qui peuvent faire des
bêtises qui peuvent être inquiétés par
la justice qui peuvent parfois des
choses contraires aux règles et doivent
être sortis de ce corps social et vous
avez parfaitement raison non nous ne
considérons pas que la menace principale
et l'ultra gauche la men principal en
France terroriste et bien évidemment la
menace islamiste 40 à 41 attentats
déjoué depuis 2017 encore un sans doute
hier grâce au service de renseignement
il y a eu 9 attentats déjoué de
l'ultra-droite depuis 2017 dont certains
de qui je suis ministre de l'Intérieur
et là encore la délégation renseignement
pourrait vous donner toutes les
informations il y en a quand même eu un
ultra gauche à la fin de de l'année 2020
une action extrêmement violente
mortifère contre des forces de l'ordre
ces personnes ont été mis en examen
présenté devant un juge et incarcéré je
constate qu'on en parle pas oui il y a
aussi menace ultra gauche à 2200
ultra gauche fichiers par la DGSI et il
y en a un petit millier pour l'ultra
droite il y en a plus de 20000 pour les
islamistes il ne faut pas comparer je
pense que il faut pas faire croire que
d'un côté alors la gauche j'irai vous
oubliez de l'extrême droite et elle a le
droit de dire extrême gauche les
extrêmes ne sont bons pour personne et
les abattre la République de la même
manière certains par la race d'autres
parlent une revendication radicale
sociale elles sont toutes tous les deux
au pire et non les services amateurs ne
choisit pas entre les deux ultras elle
les combats de la même manière mais je
sais que vous en êtes convaincus je veux
dire au ministre bas que si je comprends
sa question je me permettrais de
tempérer je voudrais lui rappeler que
Notre-Dame-des-Landes ça date pas
d'Emmanuel Macron et que je constate que
ça fait très longtemps depuis les années
70 qu'on essaie de faire un aéroport de
landes et puis compris sur les
gouvernements que vous avez servi
monsieur le ministre ou que vous avez
soutenu lorsque vous n'étiez pas
responsabilité on n'a pas évacué les
personnes qui s'occupent illégalement
des terrains nous commençons à mettre
des pieux attaquer des policiers
légendes donc vous avez raison mais je
pense que c'est ce que je dis d'ailleurs
dans le journal la lâcheté par habitude
par peur par complaisance intellectuelle
a été très collective vis-à-vis d'ultra
gauche très collective et il faut mettre
fin à ça et donc ce que j'ai dit dans le
Journal du Dimanche c'est qu'il y aura
plus de nouvelles oeuvres qui
s'installeront qu'est-ce qu'on voulait
faire dans les bassines c'est là aussi
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous pour
votre opinion mais j'ai entendu
l'introduction de Monsieur Bonhomme
c'est qu'il voulait faire une ZAD
dit souvent vous avez mis des gendarmes
pour protéger un trou c'est pas l'objet
d'abord quand bien même c'est une
décision de justice et c'est une
propriété mais c'est pas ça l'objet
l'objet est encore les notes de
renseignement vous la prendront sans
doute encore plus précisément il voulait
faire une zadine enfin la même chose
contre un des Landes d'ailleurs le
collectif Les soulèvement de la terre ce
sont des anciens très différentes
parties d'entre eux qui ont appris de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et qui faisait
partie Notre-Dame-des-Landes et l'Alsace
en tant que telle elle est insupportable
puisque c'est une zone de non-droit mais
en plus elle crée des cellules souches
pardon pour d'autres contestations et
d'autres violences bien parfois des
contre-sociétés la déscolarisation des
enfants on en parle pas assez mais il y
a une partie du train à gauche qui met
en place l'emprise en faisant des
conseils municipaux on fait démissionner
des mères dans certains départements
notamment du sud-ouest de notre pays il
faut il faut vraiment comprendre que
c'est une organisation et oui nous
essayons de rompre avec une forme de
l'acheter ou de complaisance qui a eu
avec ultra gauche est-ce qu'on a été
responsable sans doute tous les hommes
les femmes politiques de ces 30
dernières années parce qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu aller à la confrontation parce que
évidemment après il y a des violences
évidemment après on vient se justifier
devant vous monsieur le sénateur je
pense qu'on est arrivé à un point
extrêmement critique et c'est un point
européen c'est pas qu'un point français
en Grèce en Italie en Allemagne comme je
l'ai déjà évoqué donc la cellule en
tisane je répondrai en même temps
ministre de Brest c'est une cellule
juridique parce que il y a la violence
police gendarmerie casseurs mais il y a
tout le travail qui essaie de faire le
très gauche en amont la propriété des
terrains
l'entrisme dans les conseils municipaux
juridiques les contestations sans cesse
des documents d'urbanisme la pression
qui est mis aussi parfois même le
paiement en cash de certains
agriculteurs pour qu'on puisse s'y
installer parfois aussi des menaces
opérer contre certains élus ou contre
certaines autorités et donc il faut
absolument que l'État s'arme alors ça
gendarmerie nous avons évoqué mais
quelque part c'est déjà trop tard comme
vous l'avez dit mais ça aussi largement
en amont et je profite pour dire que
c'est vraiment un point important il y a
des aides en France il y en a une près
de Dijon par exemple qui pose des
problèmes importants il y a aussi des
occupations illicites on le sait tous de
terrain depuis plus de 40 ans notamment
en Île-de-France de gens qui sont
installés illégalement parfois à
quelques centaines parfois quelques
milliers de personnes et c'est très
difficile d'évacuer les ADDES donc
autant empêcher qu'elle s'installe et
donc et alors moi je sais pas s'il faut
changer la loi monsieur le ministre en
tout cas je pense qu'il faut regarder si
le ministère de l'Intérieur et d'autres
ministères ont tous les moyens pour le
faire ce qui est certain c'est que pour
répondre à votre question aussi sur les
drones les décrets sont désormais au
Conseil d'État après avoir été avec Nil
après un avis favorable à CNIL dès cet
été ne pourront faire voler les drôles
en renseignement grâce au travail
collectif que nous avons fait et qu'on
fait de rapporteurs dont vous bien
évidemment sur la PPL Retailleau
anti-casseurs moi je pense qu'il faut
remettre sur l'ouvrage parce que je
pense qu'il y a un chemin dans la
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
voilà donc je pense qu'il faudra que le
gouvernement reprenne ses
responsabilités ou que vous les preniez
ou que nous les prenions ensemble et
évidemment je veux le redire sur les sur
les ades nous devons grâce à cette
cellule de juriste faire un état des
lieux et puis en tirer les conclusions
réglementaires législatives si c'était
si c'est le cas mais je veux dire au
ministre bam a détermination évidemment
à cela mais non ce week-end là à Sainte
Soline par deux weekends d'ailleurs de
suite les personnes n'ont pas réussi à
installer de ZAD et oui l'autorité de
l'État a été respectée mais oui cela a
été violent et oui il faut se prévenir
contre cela sur je réponds aussi donc du
coup à Monsieur alamark dont je remercie
d'ailleurs de sa question pour monsieur
benaroche je rentrerai pas dans le débat
sur sur est-ce que les bassines c'est
bien ou c'est pas bien d'ailleurs je
pense que c'est pas le sujet
on peut être contre les bassines et
contre les cocktails Molotov contre les
gendarmes d'ailleurs monsieur benaroche
je crois que votre mouvement politique a
fait une erreur méthodique je pense que
si la gauche que vous représentez une
partie de la gauche que vous présentez
avait dit ce qui se passe à
sainte-solide est inacceptable il est
évident que les gendarmes ont été
agressés mais que par ailleurs dans le
mouvement social le ce que vous essayez
de faire croire les ordres étaient
donnés pour calmer le mouvement social
je pense que vous auriez été sans doute
plus entendu des Français mais là vous
avez globalisé peut-être par volonté je
dirais pas Antipolis parce que vous êtes
un homme de bien pas de vos sentiments
personnels je veux plus de d'autres
notamment oui quand on dit que les
policiers doivent se faire rééduquer
mentalement comme le dit Monsieur
Longchamp c'est une forme de terreur et
terrorisme intellectuelle c'est certain
oui ça je je dis policiers ça les aide
pas bien se porter et après on dit
pourquoi il y a des suicides chez les
policiers peut-être parce qu'on les
valorise pas tellement leur métier donc
je vous fais pas ce procès monsieur
mélange mais je crois que défendre
sainte Soline comme vous le faites
retire beaucoup à mon avis de de de
points à ceux qui défendent mais
vraiment une cause environnementale dont
il pense que ça ne passe pas par les
bassines et moi je respecte parfaitement
ce point de vue mais je suis dans
ministre dans un état de droit et moi
j'applique avec les policiers gendarmes
les décisions de justice il se trouve
qu'à sainte solide c'est pas moi Hassan
solide la justice a validé la
construction de cette bassine on peut
être pour ou contre l'extension d'un
aéroport on peut être pour continuer
d'être GV moi j'ai mon opinion
personnelle pour savoir si vous en
déplacines ou le tunnel sous la Manche
c'est mon opinion personnelle mais il se
trouve que la justice a validé le droit
de propriété et les décisions de justice
sans avoir rester à la loi dit-on c'est
quand même quelque chose que qui touche
à mon avis tous les tous les démocrates
et tous les tous les républicains non la
doctrine n'a pas été modifiée pour les
manifestations de Paris à partir de 16
mars simplement on a eu pas des gentils
manifestants mais des méchants d'ultra
gauche qui étaient dans ces
manifestations je vous encourage à vous
faire communiquer et là il y a pas
besoin de la négation de renseignement
toutes les instructions données au
préfet et au préfet de police vous
verrez que rien n'a bougé c'était la
même il y a trois mois et la même cette
journée là simplement j'ai essayé de
vous montrer que c'était très différent
alors pour Monsieur Bonhomme je trouve
ça va en partie répondu à ces questions
je pense que Monsieur Bonhomme a raison
de dire que bobard est j'essaierai de me
corriger la prochaine fois versus la loi
la loi tout bon sur Sylvain c'est
Notre-Dame-des-Landes je reviendrai pas
sur les questions précédentes et je
pense que c'est effectivement une partie
de la complaisance de lutte à gauche qui
nous touche tous et je pense avoir en
partie répondu à Monsieur à Monsieur bas
votre Zélande moi j'ai des pas mis de
l'Intérieur à l'époque mais c'est sûr
que lorsque vous faites des opérations
qui relevaient une opération extrêmement
importante de d'évacuation de la ZAD
avec parce que les enseignements à
l'époque là aussi je pense que c'est
intéressant de les de les consulter des
morts de chaque côté manifestants et
policiers gendarmerie la décision était
prise de ne pas le faire est-ce que
c'était bien de pas le faire c'est votre
opinion politique je la respecte encore
faut-il que il fallait pas laisser
installer en train de des Landes donc
c'est très difficile d'évacuer des add
pour ne pas dire c'est extrêmement
dangereux et donc le mieux c'est
d'éviter qu'elle s'installe donc pour
l'avenir moi je ne peux être que
d'accord avec vous son autorité de
l'État monsieur sénateur pour l'avenir
empêchant vous parlez de la Ligue des
droits de l'Homme je connais pas les
subventions données par l'État mais
effectivement je pense que ça mérite ça
mérite d'être regardé dans le cadre des
actions qu'ils ont pu mener mais je
rappelle que beaucoup de collectivités
locales aussi les finances
voilà non mais je dis représentant des
collectivités locales également que vous
êtes voilà donc ce n'est pas qu'une
question il n'y a pas que l'État enfin
pour Madame Mendes voudrais de ne pas
lui avoir répondu bien évidemment
d'abord ça si vous êtes l'objet de
menace d'insultes ce dont je doute pas
je les condamne évidemment extrêmement
fortement madame tourdelier a appelé mon
cabinet la semaine dernière elle est
l'objet de menacer d'insultes notamment
ses déplacements elle a été protégée par
les gendarmes de la République à la pu
faire son déplacement il y a des maires
y compris d'ailleurs qui combattent
fortement le gouvernement y compris
dupes que nous protégeons par le SDLP on
en fait pas publicité la police elle est
celle de l'ensemble des Français et
n'est pas bien sûr celle d'un parti
politique et à votre disposition si vous
sentez menacé d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas
on peut faire des évaluations et on peut
faire un accompagnement sans aucun
problème je veux vous dire Madame
sur le groupe uscule faire de terre non
seulement il a été fermé mais par
ailleurs les services de renseignement
puisque c'est désormais judiciarisé
peuvent connaître l'identité de ces
personnes et seront poursuivies et une
enquête judiciaire
a été ouverte je vous prie de croire
qu'il n'y a pas de poids de mesure
l'ultra droite et très dangereuse ultra
gauche est très dangereuse et on devrait
tous être très unis pour les condamnés
merci Monsieur le Miss alors j'ai encore
10 questions il est 12h30 une minute par
personne
donc je regarde bien parce qu'après le
ministre doit répondre et on lèvera à
13h je crois que vous êtes à
18h donc
allez monsieur bonne Carrère pour une
minute oui monsieur le ministre de
constat très rapide une question premier
constat vous donnez acte du problème
d'ultra gauche et des guérilla d'une
contestation qui sera radicalise et vous
redire que nous partageons avec vous les
enjeux d'ordre public deuxième constat
les effets de Domino vous avez parlé de
cellules souches vous avez fait
référence à Sivens au drame du jeune
Rémi Fraisse il n'y a pas de hasard si
on regarde une situation l'autorité de
l'État n'a pas été respectée au départ
nous avons eu le drame de Sylvain c'est
si vous avez cité maintenant toujours
dans mon département là 69 je pourrais
vous vous démontrer ce que j'appellerais
un arc l'élude et les liens entre les
différents sujets ma question
personne n'a intérêt à une à la violence
en général est-ce que vous auriez
monsieur le ministre des pistes pour
contribuer à une forme de désescalade je
ne vis pas dans un monde idéal mais il
n'est pas intérêt il n'est pas interdit
de regarder ce qui pourrait contribuer à
une des escalade de la violence merci de
votre attention merci Monsieur bonne
carême Jourda pour une minute ensuite
Monsieur wattublique Merci monsieur
Président Monsieur ministre un
remerciement d'abord pour le
commissariat de Lorient dont les
policiers ont effectivement été attaqués
avec une violence qu'aucune lutte
sociale ne justifie une observation sur
Notre Dame des Landes je rappelle qu'il
y a eu 179 procès tous gagnés par l'État
Notre-Dame-des-Landes exé sous le
quinquennat de Monsieur Hollande que ces
procès ont tous été purgés et qu'alors
on pouvait agir et enfin une question
vous avez beaucoup évoqué l'ultra gauche
pouvez-vous définir ce qui est l'ultra
gauche
comment on rattache les manifestants à
cet ultra gauche sachant qu'il a été
indiqué que
les consignes qui sont données c'est de
ne jamais parler de ne jamais avoir de
papier enfin et de ne jamais être
identifiable et que comptez-vous faire
contre ces mouvements si toutefois ils
sont constitués d'ultra gauche donc on
voit qu'ils sont particulièrement
nuisibles merci Madame Jordan monsieur
what's the blade et ensuite même
l'herbier merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre on a bien compris
que dans les manifestations il y a des
gens qui manifestent de façon pacifique
et bien sûr noyauté par des groupes
d'extrême donc les Black Blocs
effectivement les drones sont interdits
ma question pose principalement ces
black bloc au titre du mission intérieur
de la DSI êtes-vous en mesure de
l'identifier et de les poursuivre à prix
violence je ne suis pas sûr et forcément
on revient sur le débat sur
l'utilisation de la relance faciale qui
serait un moyen de devoir parce que
l'impunition de ces gens là c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui on les connaît pas on sait
pas qui on n'arrive pas on n'a pas les
moyens de voir qu'est-ce qui est
derrière et je crois que c'est un des
principales problèmes et puis redire
pour moi les manifestants à un moment
donné même Pacifique quand les forces de
l'ordre chargent est-ce qu'il y a encore
des consignes qui disent bien voilà ça
va se faire en deux trois temps on
prévient avant ce qui peut permettre
aussi aux gens de se reculer de pas
rester en première ligne parce qu'on a
vu qu'il y a beaucoup de blessés mais
est-ce qu'il y a encore toujours ses
consignes de sécurité en dire voilà
des sommations est-ce qu'elles sont
encore là voilà puis pour finir je dis
que le dernier mot reste doit rester à
la loi et non pas la loi de quelques-uns
dans la rue merci monsieur
trelos madame l'herbier bonne minute oui
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre c'était tout à fait intéressant
de vous entendre ce matin nous rappeler
que la démocratie devait être protégée
et vous savez qu'ici au Sénat c'est une
priorité essentielle il était bon de
vous entendre parler de cette violence
nationale et aussi européenne le schéma
de maintien de l'ordre c'est déjà adapté
plusieurs fois pour être au mieux pour
protéger au plus les citoyens et
je voudrais revenir sur
quelques points je voudrais savoir quels
sont les points essentiels sur lesquels
vous réfléchissez justement en
complément de ce que vient dire mot mon
collègue wadelen pour que ce ne soit pas
une occasion de casse
impuni comme les casseurs s'organisent
comment pouvons-nous nous parlementaire
appuyer législativement les moyens
d'apporter les preuves pour un suivi
judiciaire la preuve des fidélités doit
être suivi de sanctions tout ça c'est
forcément une obligation pour être
entendue l'identification des casseurs
on était sur le même la même idée est
difficile ils sont cagoulés ils sont
dissimulés quelle technique peuvent être
envisagées pour les repérer pour les les
suivre pour les arrêter sans équivoque
nous sommes prêts à revoir la PPL de
Monsieur Retailleau pourquoi pas c'est
essentiel que vous ayez des moyens
d'appui
merci beaucoup madame l'herbier monsieur
Jean-Yves Leconte puis ensuite madame
aribet oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre nous sommes tous
d'accord pour dire qu'il y a un problème
d'ordre républicain mais à force de
parler du nom faut pas oublier objective
républicain et je suis assez frappé de
voir en étant assez
attaché à regarder ce qui se passe dans
la vase qui s'écrit dans la presse
européenne et internationale à l'image
durablement atteinte de notre pays
compte tenu de ce qui s'y passe et de ce
qui est observé depuis quelques temps
bien entendu depuis 10 ans les
mobilisations par les réseaux sociaux
rendent le maintien de l'ordre beaucoup
plus compliqué qu'auparavant lorsqu'il
s'agissait de simplement d'échanger avec
les organisateurs pour cadrer les choses
en amont et les choses se passaient
beaucoup mieux aujourd'hui il est
essentiel d'éviter tout incompréhension
même dans l'opinion publique pour éviter
ceux qui pourraient profiter des
conflits politiques et des affrontements
le respect finalement de l'ensemble des
corps intermédiaires est indispensable
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le ministre moi je voudrais vous poser
une question très simple pensez-vous
aujourd'hui être en mesure de faire
respecter l'ordre républicain en étant
membre d'un gouvernement qui depuis 15
jours a quand même sur ces sujets
multiplier les provocations le mépris et
la morgue face aux incompréhensions et à
la volonté clairement majoritaire de la
population française
merci Monsieur Leconte madame Marie Bay
puis monsieur le kervé
très rapidement parce que vous avez
répondu en partie en répondant madame
Bensa et en ben Bassa pardon et en
répondant à Jérôme Durin je voudrais
simplement faire une remarque vous
je suis girondine et dans votre exposé
quand vous expliquez les choses vous ne
parlez que du ultra gauche alors que
vous êtes tout à fait capable de faire
des réponses équilibrées quand on vous
dit il y a aussi l'ultra droite et sur
Bordeaux vous n'avez pas précisé les
choses il se trouve qu'à Bordeaux a
priori d'après les informations que j'ai
c'était l'extrême droite plus que
l'ultra à moins que ça soit aussi de la
fake news donc je trouve que il est
regrettable que les propos qu'il y ait
besoin de poser la question pour revenir
à l'équilibre des propos et quelque part
ça joue le jeu des ultra-droites et
quand vous parlez des réseaux européens
il me semble que les dangers
actuellement sont plus dans les prises
de pouvoir de l'extrême droite plutôt
que de l'extrême gauche aujourd'hui
voilà c'est simplement je suis
satisfaite par les réponses que vous
avez faites sur cette question
d'équilibre mais je voudrais que elle
puisse cet équilibre puisse être
rencontré sans qu'on ait à poser la
question
merci Madame arrivet alors Monsieur
Louis kervé puis monsieur scène Bourgi
oui merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voulais saisir
la balle au bon et et vous faire part de
notre disponibilités
des drones en matière d'ordre public
puisque vous avez répondu à mon collègue
qu'on rapporter et je pense que c'est un
élément important que nous puissions
regarder encore une fois comment les
choses peuvent évoluer vous avez donné
un certain nombre de perspective
notamment en termes de textes
réglementaire moi le sujet est sur
lequel je vais vous interroger c'est la
question des unités locales de police et
de gendarmerie je me suis rendu auprès
de gendarmes à deux ou trois reprises
ces dernières semaines et au-delà de
sainte Soline la dégradation des
conditions des manifestations est
réelles
Muriel Jourdain vous a parlé de du
département du Morbihan moi je peux voir
vous parler de la Haute-Savoie doit
arriver des manifestants étrangers dans
des manifestations locales qui ne
se comporte absolument pas de la même
manière que
quand les manifestations sont gérées par
les organisations syndicales ça
interpelle ça interroge et je voulais
savoir si vous payez nous donner un
panorama de ce qui peut se passer dans
les dans les départements de la manière
dont vous envisagez peut-être pour
demain d'ailleurs de de gérer ces
questions d'ordre public
merci Monsieur Hervé et Monsieur sainte
Bourgi puis madame merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais commencer par saluer les forces
de l'ordre que je rencontre
régulièrement dans mon département et de
constater les conditions de travail
particulièrement difficile qui sont les
leurs et naturellement ici personne ne
confond
l'écrasante majorité des forces de
l'ordre avec quelques-uns d'entre eux
qui peuvent commettre des actes ou tenir
des propos que nous réprouvons tous et
toutes monsieur le ministre dans l'autre
pays il n'y a pas de police des mots
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure il n'y a
pas de police de la pensée je vous
l'accorde je suis d'accord complètement
d'accord avec vous en revanche dans
notre pays lorsqu'on est un responsable
politique et nous nous sommes tous et
toutes ici nous devons cultiver la
nuance nous nous donnons nous devons
nous efforcer de rechercher la vérité et
de la dire
parce que mal nommé les choses c'est
rajouter au malheur du monde comme le
disait Albert Camus dans votre exposé
luminaire vous avez répété au moins 40
fois le mot ultra gauche dans les
réponses que vous avez faites aux
questions de mes collègues vous avez
répété une quinzaine de fois le mot
ultra gauche je voulais juste vous dire
quand
lisant les articles de presse en
échangeant avec les représentants des
forces de l'ordre avec les organisations
syndicales le tableau est beaucoup plus
mitigé beaucoup plus nuancé parce
qu'effectivement il y a des personnes
qui relèvent de ce que vous appelez la
mouvance ultra gauche il y a des
personnes qui ne se revendiquent ni de
gauche ni de droite qui se disent
libertaire ou anarchiste mais il y a
aussi monsieur le ministre et vous le
savez et je regrette que vous n'ayez pas
précisé des casseurs qui viennent juste
pour chaparder et pour voler c'est le
cas dans les grandes villes c'est pas le
cas à Sainte-Souline mais à l'occasion
des manifestations ou en marge des
manifestations qui se tiennent dans les
grands centres urbains de notre pays il
y a des gens qui ne sont ni de gauche ni
de droite mais qui viennent profiter
pour casser pour s'attarder pour voler
c'est la raison pour laquelle je tenais
vraiment à insister sur ce point-là
parce qu'effectivement si on veut être
audible et crédible aux yeux de
l'opinion publique et des personnes qui
subissent ces dégradations nous devons
utiliser les bons mots monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous interroger très
précisément sur un point qui est celui
des interdictions administratives de
territoire vous les avez évoqué depuis
quelques années il y a des flux de
casseurs qui viennent de l'étranger dans
notre pays est-ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
pouvez nous dire précisément le nombre
de personnes qui ont fait l'objet d'une
iate et de quel pays venait-il merci
merci Monsieur borgy Madame Marie
Mercier puis Monsieur Henri Leroy merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre
tout le monde ici qu'on donne la
violence elle était terrifiante elle est
terrifiante d'où qu'elle vienne moi je
voudrais insister sur le climat de
violence qui règne dans notre société je
pense qu'il y a une cause même plusieurs
qui sont très profondes puisqu'elles
commencent même à la maternelle qu'elle
est violence intrafamiliale qui explose
donc nous vivons dans un climat violent
la manifestation elle était interdite
pouvez-vous me dire si c'est pour ça
qu'il n'y avait peut-être pas la Croix
Rouge ou d'autres d'autres véhicules de
secours si ils étaient là pourquoi ils
n'ont pas pu intervenir et quand il y a
eu ses blessés je n'ai pas très bien
compris pourquoi les véhicules n'ont pas
pu accéder sur les lieux plus vite vous
avez dit que des blessés empêcher
peut-être son arrivée est-ce qu'il y
avait seulement les blessés qui
s'accrochait à ce véhicule du Samu le
médecin du GIGN est intervenu semble que
lui était plus près il lui a fallu quand
même plus d'une heure pour secourir on
savait que probablement ça allait être
violent vous avez dit qu'il y avait 42
projets qui risquaient d'entraîner des
déchaînements comme ça donc est-ce que
ça peut pas être anticipé de façon à ce
que les secours au moins arrivent
arrivent plus vite
merci Madame merci et puis Monsieur
Henri Leroy
oui monsieur le Président merci merci
aussi monsieur le ministre pour toutes
les précisions que vous nous avez
apportées lors de votre intervention
illustrée par des aides pédagogiques
percutantes et significatives l'extrême
violence est en ascension vertigineuse
dans la grande majorité des pays
européens
l'ensemble des mesures d'ordre technique
juridiques et administrative ne
suffisent plus à faire face efficacement
à ce déchaînement d'exaction de violence
et de haine les groupuscules d'extrême
droite ou gauche c'est la même chose
vous les avez vous avez constaté
vous-même d'ailleurs par votre présence
sur le terrain monsieur le ministre à
Caen des mesures adéquates pour
maîtriser ces situations qui ne feront
que s'aggraver tant qu'un train de
disposition plus coercitive à la hauteur
des à hauteur de de ces menaces ne
seront pas prises les forces de l'ordre
les attendent et vous le savez puisque
vous avez été à leur contact très
souvent dernièrement merci merci
Monsieur Laura si vous me permettez une
question
je m'autorise une question
mais une minute alors une minute
monsieur godet surveille les
protestations qui sont venues de des
commissaires du Conseil de l'Europe ou
de l'ONU sont souvent connus par voie de
presse moi j'aimerais savoir si vous
avez vos services ont des contacts
directs avec ces différentes
organisations parce qu'il y a quelques
semaines la commission des lois s'est
transportée soit la CEDH soit au Conseil
de l'Europe et nous avons eu des
échanges
très intéressants et qui démontre que on
doit avoir ce dialogue en tous les cas
qui doit être plus intense mais face à
des déclarations de cette nature comment
cela est-il géré à votre niveau en tous
les cas entre le ministère et ses
organisations si toutefois cela existe
merci est-ce que je fais une minute 30
secondes
puis après nous lévrons la séance merci
monsieur le Président pour répondre
directement à votre question je les ai
découvert également par voie de presse
d'ailleurs effectivement nous avons fait
savoir parce que vous savez que en tout
cas pour ce qui est du Conseil européen
à l'ambassadeur qui est là pour que ce
serait bien qu'effectivement et on
comprend très bien les remarques ça peut
être qui peut être fait que ce serait
bien que nous puissions également
l'avoir de façon peut-être officielle
peut-être même quelques minutes avant ce
serait même une autre chose ne serait-ce
que pour qu'un contradictoire puisse
exister voilà j'espère que nous
améliorons évidemment c'est c'est
discussions d'ailleurs j'ai encouragé
que ce soit le commissaire évoqué ou le
Conseil de l'Europe à venir là aussi
rencontrer les forces de l'ordre puisque
à ma connaissance peut-être que mes
services ne disent pas tout mais je
pense que si on avait représentant de
l'ONU ou le Conseil d'Europe quelque
part on me le dirait qu'il puisse venir
voir quel service rencontrer les
policiers des gendarmes directement les
interroger et bien sûr faire ce travail
contradictoire bien évidemment
peut-être dire puisque ça a été évoqué
d'abord moi je qualifie pas l'ultra
gauche ou l'ultra droite comme faisant
partie de la droite et de la gauche et
moi ce qui m'étonne d'ailleurs dans le
retour notamment sur
l'ultra gauche et que vous regardez dire
c'est une discussion de la gauche c'est
pas la gauche c'est une à gauche ultra
droite ce sont des mouvements qui sont
qualifiés comme ça depuis très longtemps
d'ailleurs j'ai rappelé il y a pas si
longtemps que ça et c'est pas pour vos
questions c'est pas vérité historique
que ce qu'on puisse combattre ultra
gauche le service de renseignement c'est
la gauche quand elle était en
responsabilité et dire une très grande
partie des personnes qui sont affichées
au service de renseignement l'ont été
comme Manuel Valls et Bernard cazen
était mise à l'intérieur donc moi je ne
confonds pas bien évidemment le train à
gauche et la gauche d'ailleurs je
m'étonne collier pourquoi pas et
pourquoi vous dit pas assez ultra-droite
il se trouve que là
c'est l'ultra gauche je peux pas dire
autre chose Monsieur le Sénateur
d'ailleurs je dis à Madame la créatrice
non en tout cas à ma connaissance il y a
une enquête qui est ouverte mais à ma
connaissance aucune information n'est
remontée pour dire que c'était l'ultra
droite qui était responsable de ce qui
s'est passé à Bordeaux et d'ailleurs je
que un député de la France insoumise en
l'occurrence monsieur Coquerel me
semble-t-il sur une chaîne de grandes
écoute et désignée
un mouvement politique sans avoir aucune
espèce de preuve voilà si c'est à la fin
du travail je le dirai bien volontiers
je l'ai combat de la même manière à
Bordeaux j'ai dit sous l'association
Bordeaux nationaliste c'était en
décembre 2022 il y a pas si longtemps
que ça et même monsieur Mélenchon le
premier février dernier m'a félicité par
intuites qui restait archivé aux
Archives nationales tellement il est
incroyable
pour dire que j'avais pour dire que il
salue mon action je suis mise à part qui
a dissout génération identitaire
tout le monde a parlé y compris des
gouvernements précédents ça n'a pas été
fait dans des conditions très très
difficiles et validé d'ailleurs par le
Conseil d'État donc
il se trouve madame la sénatrice que
l'on m'interroge là sur ce qui s'est
passé je ne peux pas vous dire autre
chose que la vérité des faits qu'à notre
connaissance et des services de
renseignement c'est ultra gauche
maintenant si le président veut
m'inviter pour que je vous passe par la
menace accélérationniste ou suprémaciste
je le fais bien volontiers mais ce n'est
pas l'objet de l'actualité d'aujourd'hui
voilà donc n'y voyez pas quelque chose
une sorte de poursuite au théâtre pour
parler d'autre chose c'est la vérité que
je constate personnellement que je crois
beaucoup de Strasbourg constate l'ultra
gauche ou me demander une définition
on me dit même que la mairie de Bordeaux
5 individus ont été interpellé placé en
garde à vue un écrou et deux contrôle
judiciaire et jusqu'à présent à notre
connaissance mais surtout des magistrats
qui ont pu communiquer aucun lien avec
l'extrême droite confirmé ça veut pas
dire que tu auras pas de ma voix après
demain c'est à dire que personne ne peut
le dire aujourd'hui moment où nous
parlons voilà
l'ultra droite est déjà assez dangereux
comme ça pour que on lui passe par
ailleurs des des choses qu'elle aurait
manifestement pas faite encore une fois
je vais du conditionnel parce que
l'enquête te dira pour moi l'ultra
gauche puis pour les services de
renseignement aussi c'est un mouvement
ou des militants qui légitime le recours
à l'action violente parce qu'il refuse
les règles institutionnelles voilà
évidemment des causes radicales que l'on
pourrait classer social ou écologique
bien évidemment et de ce point de vue la
différence fondamentale je vous
répondrai aussi peut-être à Madame à
Madame jourdat
c'est que l'ultra droite la droite
extrême dans des actions violentes et il
y en a bien évidemment je dirais pas que
c'est plus facile pour les
renseignements c'est pas ce que je veux
dire parce qu'ils sont très dangereux
mais ils ont un souci de l'ordre et de
l'organisation qui vire à l'obsession
donc il faut des statues il faut une
hiérarchie il faut des lieux il faut
vous voyez ce que je veux dire il y a
une volonté c'est ce qui explique et ces
renseignements c'est pas moi et
d'ailleurs si vous les auditionnez vous
le diront il y a une volonté de
l'organisation de l'écriture du statut
ultra gauche et plus dans la nébuleuse
il y a plus de volonté culturelles
anarchique même si je ne confonds pas
les anarchistes avec le dragon géantes
parce que j'ai dit mais voyez ce que je
veux dire il y a moins de volonté
d'organisation et c'est plus nébuleux
c'est plus difficile il y a c'est vrai
une Internationale ultra droite mais par
nature et nationalistes alors que
l'ultra gauche par nature est plus
internationaliste d'ailleurs le fait que
l'arrivée dans des causes et que ce soit
en France ou ailleurs j'ai parlé des
manifestations du G7 ou du G20 à en
Angleterre ou en Allemagne montrent que
nous constatons qu'il y a beaucoup plus
d'échanges internationaux c'est-à-dire
qu'il y en a pas le droit ça veut dire
que ce n'est pas la même nature donc
c'est pas les mêmes mouvements c'est pas
un parallèle de miroir où on dirait ben
voilà on a deux structures qu'il
faudrait combattre c'est pas les mêmes
modes d'action il y a d'ailleurs une
paranoïa avancée très forte en Ultra
gauche qui utilise des crypto qui
utilisent des messagers cryptées que
n'utilise pas toujours
ultra-droite un peu mais pas toujours
c'est pas la même culture il y a une
culture du clandestin
ultra gauche que les battent toujours
celui de l'ultra droite qui va jusqu'à
porter des insignes donc voilà
évidemment il y a beaucoup de plus
subtilités dans la réalité de ce que
j'évoque mais ça pour vous montrer les
différences auxquelles à la difficulté
des services de renseignement sur
monsieur wabled bon et je répondrai en
même temps Madame l'herbier qui passe
finalement la même question
alors la reconnaissance faciale je suis
pas tout à fait certain que ça nous
aiderait mais en tout cas je me suis
déjà exprimé sur ce point ce qui est
certain c'est que dans l'identité des
personnes
il y a
un travail très fort que mettre en place
de contournement les extrémistes
violents pour éviter d'être identifiés
et d'ailleurs une partie de ces
personnes pas toutes mais une partie
font partie des cases bourgeoises pour
parler voilà j'ai moi-même dit j'ai
essayé de démontrer par un jeu de mots
je sais que le second degré n'est pas
dans les rendez-vous politiques et
idétiques mais il y a un petit côté
black Bourges tous les services de
renseignement les politiques vont
rencontrer vous dites mais vous savez
c'est pas des gens des quartiers ou des
cités qui font ça c'est pas les ouvriers
en colère qui font ça c'est beaucoup
d'enfants de bonne famille Kaby dans des
bosses arrondissements parisiens qui ont
des professions ou qui sont sur des
études extrêmement importantes et qui
trouvent un intérêt à la violence est-ce
que c'est un intérêt passager ou est-ce
que ça intéresse continue
l'avenir nous le dira mais enfin c'est
pas très nouveau ceux qui font la
révolution dans la rue contestataire
c'est rarement les fils ouvriers ça peut
arriver mais enfin chacun se rappelle
des exemples dans notre histoire et donc
par nature ils sont plusieurs organisés
ils ont compris le principe général de
l'action de la police et de la
gendarmerie et l'action de la justice
d'ailleurs vous savez moi je suis allé
voir les CRS à Lambersart parce que
Lille avait été très touché par les
manifestation ils m'ont donné les
documents que qu'ils ont trouvé sur les
personnes et de ce document tout aussi
bien fait que ce que je vous ai montré
il y avait non seulement comment
s'équiper mais quel cabinet d'avocats
appelé parce qu'il faut appeler lui
plutôt que tel autre qu'est-ce qu'il
faut dire au service de police dans la
garde à vue quelqu'un qui est violent
parce que il est touché dans son usine
dans sa famille ça peut arriver c'est
évidemment une excusable mais ça peut
arriver il n'est pas dans l'organisation
de la violence il est dans la
spontanéité de la violence des dockers
qui sont en colère ça peut être très
violent évidemment mais ils ont pas
organisé la violence et la revendique
même de faire que la violence est un
mode d'action pour faire entendre leurs
causes là il y a une part de
dissémination et d'organisation qui
devrait nous inquiéter il y a une
organisation derrière tout ça alors
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire vous savez
moi je pense que principal dans le
trafic de drogue d'ailleurs on pourrait
en parler comme dans ces manifestations
c'est que nous continuons avec le même
travail de renseignement qui est
c'est-à-dire les écoutes téléphoniques
classiques mais écoutez les classiques
donnent de moins en moins de choses
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
utilisez nous utilisons télégram signal
WhatsApp c'est-à-dire pas les lignes
téléphoniques classiques si les gens
honnêtes comme vous le font les jambes
malhonnêtes le font par définition
puisque ils savent que c'est par là
qu'ils ne sont pas entendus et donc ce
que vous nous avez autorisé en
terrorisme c'est à dire la captation à
distance et la possibilité d'aller
utiliser la technologie pour prendre en
main votre téléphone toujours sur le
contrôle de la Commission nationale des
techniques de renseignement est toujours
sous le contrôle de la justice vous
devriez pardon mais nous l'autoriser
dans la lutte contre les trafiquants de
stups qui ont beaucoup plus
d'organisations que le terrorisme
parfois ou dans les actions extrêmement
violentes je vous dis que de la terreur
pourrait s'installer pour surveiller
l'ultra-droite pour sauver l'ultra
gauche il faut je vais pas rentrer dans
le détail mais pour connaître le groupe
télégram évoqué tout à l'heure pendant
la même de ça il faut un travail humain
c'est pas un travail technique puisque
nous ne pouvons pas rentrer sur
télégramme vous nous l'autorisez pas
donc si vous voulez donner les moyens à
l'état de ce protéger mais ça pose des
tas de questions de liberté publique de
liberté individuelle d'échange
d'information qui sont bien plus
complexes que les quelques instants que
j'évoquais à vous donnez-nous en
terrorisme ce que donnez-nous pour le le
trafic de stupe de grande ampleur pour
la criminalité organisée et pour la
violence des extrêmes les mêmes
techniques de renseignement que vous
donnez pour le terrorisme le terrorisme
je dis pas que demain soir ou ce soir ou
demain matin il y aura pas un attentat
il y en a quand même eu 41 des jouets
depuis 2017 et je vous signale qu'en
corrière le service de renseignement
alors ça fait pas de bruit tant mieux
vont interpeller y compris
un adolescent de 14 ans qui se retrouve
avec des choses extrêmement dangereuses
chez lui et dont on pense on peut penser
il y a une enquête que ça aurait pu
donner quelque chose de très grave et
c'était encore le cas il y a trois mois
et c'est quasiment le cas tous les
trimestres vous nous avez donné les
moyens de lutter contre ça la loi
aujourd'hui ne donne pas forcément les
moyens de répondre à cette nouvelle
menace en tout cas continuez à faire les
écouter téléphoniques à la papa au
moment où tout le monde utilise des
messages écrit cryptés c'est peut-être
donner mettre une main dans le dos au
policier gendarme pour lutter pour notre
sécurité voilà j'ai déjà dire attention
de la commission la commission des lois
je crois que j'ai répondu donc pour
Bordeaux pour Monsieur Hervé je pense en
partie avoir répondu à cela mais je veux
dire qu'il a raison de dire que la
nature des manifestations change alors
c'est vrai c'est pas vrai parce que sur
ce manifestation il y en a 98 qui se
passe très très bien j'ai l'habitude de
dire le préfet de police tous les
vendredis il vient me voir et il me
montre une carte de Paris et vous
verriez c'est quand votre remise à
l'intérieur Monsieur Hervé vous aurez 30
manifestations à gérer tous les
week-ends les opposants à tel
gouvernement si les sans-papiers là les
professeurs en colère les médecins pas
contents les parlementaires chirales les
manifestations et parfois des raisons
très importantes
et c'est le cas partout en France la
difficulté c'est que dans certaines
manifestations quand vous l'avez dit il
y a non seulement le train gauche et de
la violence mais par ailleurs il y a à
la fois c'est ce qu'a dit je crois tout
à l'heure monsieur monsieur Bourget il y
a pas les mêmes services d'ordre qu'il y
a 30 ans
c'est un fait et il y a des personnes
étrangères qui sont les professionnels
de la contestation et donc oui nous
réfléchissons avec les polices
européennes à essayer de comprendre ce
phénomène qui est un phénomène
inquiétant que nous pensons qui est
organisé et que j'essaie d'évoquer pour
Monsieur Bourgy je voudrais rappeler
qu'il y a donc
488 iat actuellement en vigueur bon il
n'est pas là mais je suis sûr qu'il nous
entendra et par ailleurs il y en a eu
une dizaine pour sainte Soline
c'est-à-dire il y a-t-elle est toujours
notifiée c'est-à-dire qu'on a pu voir
les personnes c'est pas comme une
arrêtée quelconque qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas valable il y a T c'est donc
l'interdiction d'entrer sur le
territoire national beaucoup du train
gauche ont du stabiliste ou très droite
ont des iat et donc par définition sont
bloquées sans qu'on en prenne puisque
c'est choisir elle est plutôt prise
auparavant
la question de monsieur bonnekare est
une question importante il a raison et
j'ai cité muret j'espère de pas être
pédant en cité en citant René Girard qui
pense effectivement que la violence est
mimétique et que c'est sûr que quand on
va pas vers des escalades le bouc
émissaire arrive alors c'est les
policiers c'est qui on veut et que il
veut essayer de faire descendre cette
violence pimétique comme dans tout il
explique ainsi la vie du christianisme
mais on pourrait expliquer évidemment
dans plein d'autres choses oui on y
réfléchit mais j'allais dire que les
policiers des gendarmes sont sur place
et que les gens sont c'est déjà trop
tard alors il y en a qui le font on
essaie de le faire peut-être pas assez
bien peut-être qu'il faut qu'on
s'améliore mais je pense que c'est très
en amont et si vous permettez Monsieur
l'utilisateur je pense pas que ce soit
du ressort exclusif du ministère de
l'intérieur j'ai eu l'occasion
d'expliquer notamment sur les les
interventions des policiers des
gendarmes c'est que Miss à l'intérieur
c'est l'équivalent du Samu pour la
médecine nous intervenons en urgence on
sauve on sauve pas bien sûr on peut
toujours discuter du délai
d'intervention est-ce qu'ils ont les
bons équipements mais en vrai c'est pas
le médecin du Samu qui sauve la vie
profondément de la au moment où ça se
passe quand il fait la vaisselle quand
il fait la crise cardiaque mais c'est 30
ans de médecine préventive qu'il fallait
faire auparavant pour éviter que la
personne soit gros carré de fumer qu'il
fasse du sport qui découvre le cancer
donc Miss à l'intérieur on se retrouve
toujours vers lui je suis très heureux
devant vous et de temps en temps de
faire la ligne de l'actualité à mon
détriment parce que je protège j'essaie
de protéger les policiers gendarmes mais
c'est quand on l'appelle quand tous ces
malpassés auparavant voilà et donc oui
des escalades sans doute à obtenir à
avoir
il faut réfléchir à cette question je
crois qu'elle dépasserait largement les
cas de mon ministère qui eux sont pris
dans l'urgence de l'action évidemment
essaie de répondre avec leur moyen et je
terminerai par Madame Mercier pour lui
dire que je comprends sa question sur
les secours je voudrais quand même dire
que pour une manifestation interdite
et alors même que et c'est très
important notamment pour les enquête
judiciaires qui souffrent que personne
ne rappelle c'est les organisateurs qui
prévoit les services de secours c'est
toujours comme ça que ça fonctionne hein
c'est pas je fais une manifestation de
ce que je m'aperçois qu'il y a un
problème et je me retrouve envers le
maire pour dire pourquoi derrière prix
bah non quand vous étiez mère vous
disiez bah cher ami il y a un truc c'est
pour ça que c'est des cas en préfecture
vous avez des conditions il y a des ERP
c'est voilà les ERP l'instruction
préfectorale c'est pas pour pour faire
joli dans le décor donc c'est toujours
aux horizons de le faire ils n'ont pas
répondu organisateur malgré tout la
préfète a mobiliser des moyens sans
précédent de secours
très véhicules du 10 je remercie d'avoir
le département des Deux-Sèvres deux
hélicoptères un agenda Marie et a du
SMUR pour les secours 5 équipes du Smur
pendant ce temps-là ils ont pas à
soigner les personnes qui étaient en
urgence dans la zone dans la zone Ouest
et trois équipes médicales du GIGN bon
pour quelqu'un qui devient rien
organiser la préfète a fait son travail
après la difficulté qu'on a eu c'est les
géolocalisations encore une fois comme
ces personnes n'avaient quasiment pas de
téléphone portable pas d'identité dans
un champ de 6 km trouver les personnes
dans la foule et dans la violence parce
que les personnes ont été blessées
pendant les affrontements madame la
série ils ont pas été blessés à Paris il
fallait les retrouver parmi cette voilà
d'ailleurs vous lirez dans le document
vous le laisserai monsieur le Président
vous pourrez distribuer si vous le
souhaitez que la consigne qui était
faite aux personnes c'était si vous êtes
blessé
soyez transportés par les Street Medic
et pas par les gendarmes parce qu'ils
vont vous amener à l'hôpital c'est quand
même une drôle de consigne il faut bien
avouer on aurait pu aussi arrêter les
affrontements du côté des casseurs pour
dire il y a quelqu'un blessé enlèvera le
drapeau blanc ça n'a pas été fait et il
y a même des violences envers les
personnes qui sont dû soutenir et
soigner les policiers et les et les
gendarmes et dans l'arrivée du SMUR ou
dans notamment pour la personne qui
entre la vie et au moment où nous
parlons encore évidemment nous avons une
pensée pour elle et pour sa famille à
l'arrivée du SMUR il y a eu les deux
dans votre question il y a eu les
blessés qui l'ont interpellé moi je suis
blessé je vais à la tête j'ai mal au
bras soignez-moi et là les gens ils ont
fait ce qu'ils ont pu ils ont dit mais
non mais il y a quelqu'un qui
manifestement est plus gravement blessé
mais pendant ça ils ont été retardés
d'ailleurs il y a des images qui est sûr
que sur Internet du SMUR qui a du mal à
la fin de la foule et puis il y a eu
indépendamment de ceux qui veulent se
soigner des gens qui ont pris à partie
de corps médical au sens violent du
terme le patron du Samu des Deux-Sèvres
a dû s'expliquer à la télévision
plusieurs fois il a enfin été entendu
par une partie de la presse en disant
que jamais les gendarmes l'avaient
empêché de y aller mais que
effectivement au bout d'un moment ils
sont 10 c'est trop dangereux pour nous
c'est normal d'abord de sécuriser avant
de pouvoir porter secours c'est logique
pour les personnes de santé et que
évidemment ils ont aussi connu ces
violences donc il y a des enquêtes
judiciaires qui sont mis en place elles
sont tout à fait logiques bien
évidemment c'est c'est évident que la
police à gendarmerie fourniront comme la
préfète tous les éléments mais moi je
veux dire en tant que chef de mon
administration que la préfète a bien agi
que cette opération a été bien préparée
les gendarmes ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu
dans des conditions d'extrême violence
et qu'il ne faut pas retourner les
valeurs si les gendarmes ont été
agressés c'est parce qu'il y avait des
agresseurs si les gendarmes avaient été
seules devant les bassines madame
sénatrice il se serait pas passé grand
chose ils auraient passé un moment
bucolique dans les campagnes des
Deux-Sèvres simplement ils ont en phase
2 un millier de personnes qui ont acheté
des cocktails Molotov à la tête
merci monsieur le ministre nous arrivons
au terme de notre réunion simplement
pour dire avant que tout le monde se
précipite à ses occupations que au sein
de la commission
nous apprécions le débat mais que nous
ne céderons pas à la tentation du
Commentaire facile ici et que nous
défendrons sans relâche vraiment les
règles et l'ordre républicain auquel
nous sommes tous très attachés merci